HAPPY NEW YEAR TO EACH AND
EVERYONE OF YOU THE SENATE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE WILL COME TO
ORDER WEEK WELCOME ALL MEMBERS
WHO ARE PARTICIPATING HERE IN
ROOM FORTY TWO OH THREE AND
THOSE WHO WERE IN THE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY TODAY
WE'RE GONNA START THE SENATE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE AS A SUB
COMMITTEE AT THIS TIME. WE'LL
GET A QUORUM HERE IN JUST A FEW
MOMENTS IN RESPONSE TO THE KOBE
NINETEEN EMERGENCY TO PROTECT
THE PUBLIC LEGISLATE TORS AND
EMPLOYEES WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO
LIMIT NONESSENTIAL GATHERING
SITTING HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCE
SCENE IN FACE COVERING
GUIDELINES. WE'RE GONNA BE
HOLDING COMMITTEE HEARINGS HERE
IN THE CAPITAL WITH SOME OF OUR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY WE'RE GOING T WELCOME
THOSE ARE PARTICIPATING REMOTELY
NOW WE ARE GRATEFUL THAT CENTER
LABOR CENTER CHOI BOGUE INCENTER
DOLLY WILL BE PER PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY TODAY GOOD MORNING TO.
EACH AND EVERYONE OF YOU- WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT FOR FOLKS
ARE PARTICIPATING REMOTELY WE
WELCOME AND ENCOURAGE YOUR
PARTICIPATION WE ASK THAT EVERY
TIME YOU WISH TO BE RECOGNIZED
THAT YOU USE THE RAISE THE HAND
FEATURE. WITHIN THE PROGRAM YEAH
WE'VE ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC INTO THE HEARING ROOM
HERE IN FORTY TWO OH THREE TO
THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW
WE'RE ALSO GONNA BE USING A LIVE
TELECONFERENCING SERVICE FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY TODAY WE WELCOME THAT OF
COURSE. TODAY'S TOLL FREE
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS.
844-291-6364 YOU'RE GOING TO USE
THAT ACCESS CODE THAT'S
CURRENTLY ON YOUR SCREEN IN
PLEASE CALL EIGHT FOUR FOUR. TWO
NINE ONE SIX THREE SIX FOUR TO
TRY TO REMIND FOLKS ARE GONNA BE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY PLEASE
MUTE YOUR DEVICE PRIOR TO
SPEAKING JUST SO WE AVOID THAT
FEEDBACK. IN THE UNLIKELY EVENT
THAT SOMEONE DOES BECOME
DISRUPTIVE WEATHER ON OUR
TELECONFERENCE LINER RIGHT HERE
IN ROOM FORTY TWO OH THREE THAT
INDIVIDUAL WILL BE REMOVED FROM
THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE OR.
RIGHT HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM-
WE BEGAN WITH EVER USED. WELCOME
AND GENTLEMEN WE'RE GOING TO
WELCOME AMANDA REACH. SHE'S
GOING TO BE THE REPUBLICAN
EDUCATION CONSULTANT WE'RE
THRILLED TO BE WORKING WITH
AMANDA AND- WE WELCOME YOU LOOK
FORWARD TO OUR- CONTINUED WORK
TOGETHER. NOW AS WE SAY WELCOME
TO ONE WE'RE GOING TO SAY HOW
GRATEFUL WE ARE IN A GOOD BYE TO
ANOTHER. AND FOR THAT I'M GOING
TO TURN IT OVER TO CENTER LEYVA.
TO TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
BRINGING CENTER LEYVA THE FLOOR
IS YOURS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SENATOR MCGUIRE GOOD MORNING
EVERYONE I AM VERY SORRY I'M NOT
THERE WITH YOU IN PERSON TODAY
BUT- RIGHT NOW VERY GRATEFUL FOR
TECHNOLOGY. SO IT'S WITH A HEAVY
HEART I AM VERY RELUCTANT TO SAY
THAT WE MUST SAY FAREWELL TO.
BRANDON DARNELL OUR CONSULTANT
HERE ON SENATE EDUCATION HE
SERVED ON THIS COMMITTEE FOR
FIVE YEARS AND THEN AN
OUTSTANDING JOB HE'S GOING BACK
TO LET'S COUNCIL- WHERE HE WILL
ONCE AGAIN WORK ON THE EDUCATION
DEPARTMENT. I JUST PERSONALLY
HAVE TO SAY HOW MUCH HELP
BRANDON HAS BEEN TO ME. HE TAKES
THINGS SO SERIOUSLY MAKE SURE
YOU GET ALL THE DETAILS WORKED
WITH EVERYONE HE'S TIRELESS IN
HIS EFFORTS FOR EDUCATION. SO
EVEN THOUGH WE WILL MISS HIM AND
US TO IT XF COMMITTEE. BUT WE DO
GREAT WORK FOR US AND LET'S
CANCEL THANK YOU FOR EVERYTHING
BRANDON WE APPRECIATE YOUR- WELL
SAID THANK YOU SO MUCH CENTER
LEYVA AND BRANDON WILL BE
MISSING IF YOU DO HEAR ANY
CUSSING. THAT IS THE CHIEF
CONSULTANT. LANE RIGHT NOW AS
HE'S LEAVING SO. THERE WE GO-
BUT AGAIN BRANDON THANK YOU SO
MUCH. LAYS IN GERMAN AGAIN WE
ARE GOING TO BE STARTING IN AS A
SUB COMMITTEE WE WILL CALL THE
ROLL AND ESTABLISH A QUORUM ONCE
WE HAVE. THE ADEQUATE NUMBER OF
MEMBERS PRESENT. SO WE'RE NOW
GOING TO BE MOVING INTO OUR
REGULARLY SCHEDULED AGENDA. WE
HAVE OUR- FIVE WE WILL HEARING
FIVE BILLS NO BILLS WILL BE A
CONSENT TODAY ALL ARE UP FOR
ACTION. AND WE'RE GOING TO
WELCOME SENATOR RUBIO WHO WILL
BE PRESENTING SENATE BILL THREE
ON BEHALF OF THE GOOD SENATOR
SENATOR CAFIERO. CENTER RUBIO
IT'S ALWAYS WONDERFUL TO SEE YOU
WE WELCOME YOU PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK YOU AND GOOD MORNING TO
EVERYONE- AND THANK YOU TO. OPT
CHAIR AND MAKE WIRE AND I NOTE
THAT CHAIR IS LISTENING-
REMOTELY. I AM PLEASED TO BE
HERE TO PRESENT S. B. ABOUT
THREE ON BEHALF OF SENATOR COVER
YET- WHICH WILL PROVIDE THE
STATE WITH AN OPPORTUNITY TO
ASSESS THE IMPACT THE FUNDS
DEDICATED TO CLOSING THE STUDENT
ACHIEVEMENT GAPS. SB THREE
REQUIRES THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION TO
DEVELOP A LOCAL CONTROL AND
ACCOUNTABILITY PLAN PORTAL. TO
SERVE AS A TRACKING MECHANISM
FOR SCHOOL DISTRICTS COUNTY
OFFICES OF EDUCATION AND CHARTER
SCHOOLS TO REPORT THE SERVICES
FUNDED BY SUPPLEMENTAL AND
CONCENTRATION GRANTS.
ADDITIONALLY THE BILL REQUIRES
ELEAZAR RECEIVED THESE GRANTS TO
REPORT THE SERVICES FUNDED BY
THEM VIA THE LOCAL CONTROL AND
ACCOUNTABILITY PLAN. PORTAL THAT
IS CREATED. GIVEN THE ON GOING.
A COPY NINETEEN PANDEMIC OUR
STUDENTS HAVE FACED CONTINUOUS
BARRIERS AS A FORMER CLASSROOM
TEACHER I UNDERSTAND FIRSTHAND
THE DETRIMENTAL EFFECTS AND
IMPACTS STUDENTS WILL
EXPERIENCE. AS THE AFTERMATH OF
THIS PANDEMIC THE CONSEQUENCES
OF SCHOOLS CLOSING UNEVEN
DISTANCE LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES%
AND IT'S SEVERE ECONOMIC CRISIS
HAS FURTHER DISPROPORTIONATELY
AFFECTED OUR MOST VULNERABLE.
STUDENT POPULATIONS IT IS MORE
IMPORTANT NOW THAN EVER TO
ENSURE THAT FUNDS MEANT TO
SUPPORT HIGH NEED STUDENTS WILL
BE USED FOR THAT PURPOSE. DURING
THIS CRITICAL TIME IN OUR
STATE'S HISTORY. SB THREE WILL
CREATE A MECHANISM TO TRACK
INVESTMENTS IN EDUCATION RELATED
SERVICES FOR FOSTER YOUTH LOW
INCOME STUDENTS AND ENGLISH
LEARNERS. CURRENTLY EL CAP
REPORTS HAVE US ARE SEGMENTED IN
A STRUCTURE THAT IS UNFIT TO POP
FOR PUBLIC CONSUMPTION. AND IT
IS EVEN MORE DIFFICULT TO
UNDERSTAND THE EXACT IMPACT OF
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS DEDICATED TO
SCHOOL FUNDING. INFORMATION
GATHERED BY THESE REPORTS HAVE
FAILED TO CAPTURE EXACTLY HOW
MUCH MONEY INTENDED TO IMPROVE
LEARNING OUTCOMES FOR
UNDERSERVED STUDENTS MAINTAINS
ITS PURPOSE. THE PORTAL WILL
SERVE AS AN ONLINE TOOL TO
IMPROVE THE TRANSPARENCY OF
SPENDING DECISIONS AND PROMOTE
SHARING BEST PRACTICES AMONG
LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES. THIS
BILL WILL ALLOW THE LEGISLATURE
TO UNDERSTAND THE IMPACT OF
EQUITY INVESTMENTS IN EDUCATION.
ASSESS THE MEASURES FUNDED TO
SERVE CALIFORNIA'S MOST
VULNERABLE PUPILS AND SIMPLIFY
THE ALL CAP REPORTING METHODS TO
MAKE VALUABLE INFORMATION EASY
TO UNDERSTAND FOR THE PUBLIC.
AND THE DECISION MAKERS WITH ME
TODAY TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
SB THREE IS ROBERT BUT WARNING
FROM CHILDREN NOW AND CURSED AND
FERAL FROM THE LOS ANGELES
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT. AND AN
ALTERNATE OVER TO THEM THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH MADAM
SENATORS WONDERFUL TO SEE YOU
ALL RIGHT LAYS IN GERMAN WE HAVE
TO LEAVE IT'S A WITNESSES WERE
GOING ASK OUR LEAD SUPPORT
WITNESSES TO BE TO PROVIDE THEIR
TESTIMONY IN TWO MINUTES- EACH
IN OUR OF COURSE GIVE YOU A
THIRTY SECOND WARNING. FOR IT'S
GOING TO BE GOING TO ROBERT
ROBERT REPRESENTS CHILDREN NOW
ROBERT YOU ARE NOW LIVE IN
EDUCATION COMMITTEE PLEASE
PROCEED TO HAVE TWO MINUTES.
THANK YOU SO MUCH I'M ROBERT VAN
OR IN SENIOR ADVISOR CHILDREN
NOW CHILDREN NOW ALONG WITH OUR
CO SPONSORS TEACH PLUS. THE
EDUCATION TRUST WEST IMPAIRED
REVOLUTIONARY HERE TO SUPPORT SB
THREE. THE LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING
FORMULA WILL ALLOCATE SEVENTY
BILLION DOLLARS. IN THIS NEXT
BUDGET MAKING IT THE SINGLE
LARGEST ITEM IN THE STATE BUDGET
IN THAT SEVENTY BILLION DOLLARS
AS OF ELEVEN A HALF BILLION
DOLLARS. OF SUPPLEMENTAL AND
CONCENTRATION GRANTS MONEY WHICH
IS FOCUSED ON THE NEEDS OF
ENGLISH LEARNERS LOW INCOME
STUDENTS AND FOSTER YOU. SO
THERE IS THIS MASSIVE INVESTMENT
YET LITTLE OVERSIGHT OF THIS
FUNDING. SB THREE WAS GOING TO
HELP SB THREE WILL PROVIDE
GREATER STATE OVERSIGHT OF THIS
SPENDING. IN ADDITION IT WILL
STRENGTHEN THE SYSTEM OF
TO IDENTIFY BEST PRACTICES FROM
DISTRICTS TO MEET THEIR LOCAL.
ACCOUNTABILITY PLAN GOALS- AND
FINALLY IT'S GOING TO SUPPORT
THE ENGAGEMENT AT EDUCATORS. AND
COMMUNITY PARTNERS. IN THE
PLANNING PROCESS. THIS BILL
BUILT ON AN EXISTING PROJECT
THAT WAS STARTED IN THE TWENTY
TWENTY BUDGETS. TO COLLECT AND
PROVIDE ACCESS TO INFORMATION IN
THE OVER TWO THOUSAND HOW CAPS
WRITTEN ACROSS THE STATE. THIS
INITIAL PROJECT BEGAN IN TWENTY
TWENTY WHAT IS JUST IN ITS
INFANCY- AND DOESN'T HAVE A
SPECIFIC LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR
GOAL SB THREE PROVIDES THE
DIRECTORS A GOLD SPECIFICALLY.
IT ESTABLISHES LEGISLATIVE
PRIORITIES FOR THE PORTAL.
REQUIRES DISTRICTS TO
PARTICIPATE BY TRANSFERRING DATA
FROM THEIR L. CAPS. IN A LECTERN
A TEMPLATE INTO THE PORTAL AND
THEN REQUIRED THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION TO DESIGN QUERY TOOLS.
TO PROVIDE EDUCATORS AND
EDUCATIONAL PARTNERS INCLUDING
PARENTS THIRTY SECONDS AND
COMMUNITY GROUPS WITH ACCESS. TO
THAT EL CAP DATA. WE BELIEVE
THAT THIS IS A PART. THAT WILL
STRENGTHEN THE- OF THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF L. CHIP THAT.
CAN ACCOUNTABILITY SYSTEM THE
STATE IS BUILT WE ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT FOR SENATE BILL THREE
I'M AVAILABLE TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE BILL. THANK
YOU SO MUCH AT THE ROBERT FROM
CHILDREN NOW WE'RE NOT GONNA BE
GOING TO KEROSENE KEROSENE IS A
HARDWORKING TEACHER FROM VENICE
HIGH WITHIN THE- LA UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT. KIRSTEN WE
WELCOME YOU TO THE EDUCATION
COMMITTEE YOUR NOW LIVE YOU HAVE
TWO MINUTES AND I'LL GIVE YOU A
THIRTY SECOND PROMPT PLEASE
PROCEED. THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING
CARE LEYVA AND EDUCATION
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. MY NAME IS
KIRSTEN FARRELL AND I'M
CURRENTLY THE ATHLETIC TRAINING
COORDINATOR FOR THE LOS ANGELES
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT. BEFORE
MY NEW ROLE THIS SEMESTER I WAS
THE LEAD TEACHER FOR THE C. T.
E. SPORTS MEDICINE PATHWAY AT
BETTER CYCLE. FOR TWENTY YEARS.
I WAS THE TWO THOUSAND AND
EIGHTEN CALIFORNIA TEACHER OF
THE YEAR. AND I AM CURRENTLY
SERVING AS THE TEACH PLUS
CALIFORNIA POLICY FELLOW. I AM
HERE IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE. AS
A LONGTIME EDUCATOR I SEE THE
POWER OF LISTENING TO STUDENTS
FAMILIES AND EDUCATORS. TO BEST
ADDRESS THE NEEDS OF OUR
COMMUNITY. BUT UNDERSTANDING THE
EL CAPITAN THE L. CAP PROCESS IS
NOT ALWAYS EASY. FOR EXAMPLE AN
L. A. U. S. T. R. L. CAP IS A
FOUR HUNDRED PAGE DOCUMENT. I
CONSIDER MYSELF TO BE A PRETTY
EDUCATED INDIVIDUAL. BUT IS
STILL TEDIOUS TO TRY TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT IT MEANS FOR MY
SCHOOL AND MY STUDENTS. IN
ADDITION HOW CAN WE EXPECT OUR
PARENTS. MANY OF WHOM ARE NOT
NATIVE ENGLISH SPEAKERS AND MAY
NOT HAVE HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO
FURTHER THEIR OWN EDUCATION.
UNDERSTAND THE MYRIAD OF
COMPLEXITIES. AND FEEL THAT
THEIR OPINIONS ARE VALUED.
ADDITIONALLY AS A FORMER HIGH
SCHOOL TEACHER I SEE THE VALUE
OF ASKING STUDENTS DIRECTLY WHAT
THEY NEED. BUT HOW CAN WE EXPECT
STUDENTS TO UNDERSTAND THESE
MASSIVE DOCUMENTS AND ENGAGE
WITH THEM. SB THREE IS AN
ESSENTIAL STEP TO ENSURE THAT
THE STATE IS HELPING TO MAKE
THIS INFORMATION UNDERSTANDABLE
TO FAMILIES AND EDUCATORS THIRTY
SECONDS WE NEED TO SEE HOW IT IS
AT ALL AS THAT'S MEANT FOR HIGH
NEED STUDENTS ARE HELPING THEM.
AND LEARNING FROM OTHER
DISTRICTS THAT HAVE HAD THE
SUCCESS WITH THE STUDENT GROUP.
I URGE THE STATE LEGISLATOR SURE
TO PASSED SB THREE TO PROVIDE
ESSENTIAL INFORMATION TO ENSURE
HEALTHY UP AT ITS FULFILLING ITS
PROMISE. NOT JUST FOR MY
STUDENTS BUT FOR ALL THE
STUDENTS IN CALIFORNIA THEY ARE
OUR FUTURE AND THEY CAN'T AFFORD
FOR US TO WAIT. THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK TODAY. YOU
SO MUCH FOR BEING WITH US INTO
OF COURSE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
DEDICATION TO OUR STUDENTS
ESPECIALLY IN THESE CHALLENGING
TIMES OR- THOSE ARE TO LEAD
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF SB
THREE. GOING TO ASK THE MANY IN
THE MEMBERS FOR PARTICIPATING
HERE IN FORTY TWO OH THREE AS
WELL AS REMOTELY. WE CAN PLEASE
PAUSE FOR A MOMENT WE'RE GOING
TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM. LANE
PLEASE PROCEED. SENATOR LEYVA
HERE LEYVA HERE OF CHAU ABOVE
PRESENT TROUBLE HERE CORTESE
YOUR CORTES A HERE DELHI. YELEY
HERE KELLY HERE GLAZER- GLAZER
HERE MCGUIRE HERE REQUIRE HERE
PAN HERE AND HERE IF THE COURT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH READING CHIEF
CONSULTANT VERY GRATEFUL QUORUM
HAS BEEN ESTABLISHED LADIES AND
GENTLEMAN WE'RE NOT GONNA BE
GOING INTO OUR PARTICIPATION
PORTION OF THIS BILL HEARING
WE'RE GOING TO BE CHECKING IN TO
SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE IN SUPPORT
OF SB THREE IN ROOM FORTY TWO-
THREE IF SO PLEASE STAND NOW.
SEEN KNOWING STAN LEGS IN GERMAN
WE'RE NOT GONNA BE GOING TO OUR
TELECONFERENCE LINE WE WELCOME
ANY AND ALL PARTICIPATION TODAY
LET'S CHECK IN WITH MR MODERATOR
MR MODERATOR GOOD MORNING HAPPY
NEW YEAR TO YOU IF YOU COULD
PLEASE QUEUE UP ANY INDIVIDUAL
IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE. NOW YES
IF WHICH SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THIS LEGISLATION PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO WE DO HAVE Q. TWO
IN QUEUE AT THE MOMENT. I WILL
GO TO ONE TWENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD
. GOOD MORNING I'M SARAH WILL
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF TEACHING
CALIFORNIA POUNDS SPONSOR IN
SUPPORT OF SB THREE. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PHONE CALL LET'S GO TO
THE NEXT LINE. YES WE HAVE ONE
THIRTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
BRENDAN TELLING ON BEHALF OF AND
VOICE IN SUPPORT EXPANDING NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. NEXT WE HAVE LINE
TWENTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. AB
ONE REPRESENTING AMERICAN
ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS CALIFORNIA
DIVISION WE ARE IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU LYDIA LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT
LINE MOST MODERN. NEXT WE HAVE
WORN THIRTY TWO PLEASE. GOOD
MORNING JEFF USUALLY ON BEHALF
OF GOVERNOR FOR CALIFORNIA
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU SO MUCH AS HE COULD HEAR
VOICES GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER.
NEXTWAVE LINE THIRTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS THIS IS
BRIAN RIVAS ON BEHALF OF THE
EDUCATION TRUST WEST A CO
SPONSOR AND HAPPY TO BE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU SO MUCH BRIAN
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NEXT IN LINE
NINETEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING CHARLES RIGHT ON BEHALF
OF KIDS SO CAL IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF SB THREE THANK YOU. DEAR BOYS
HAVE BEEN HERE MISTER RIGHT
THAT'S CORRECT CALLER. AND WE
HAVE NO ONE ELSE INTO IT THIS
TIME SHARE THANK YOU SO MUCH AS
A MODERATOR WE'RE NOT GOING TO
GO TO THOSE WHO MAY BE OPPOSED
TO SP THREE. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN COMMITTEE WE DON'T
HAVE ANY LEAD OPPOSITION
WITNESSES ON FILE TODAY SO WE'RE
GONNA GO STRAIGHT TO ROOM FORTY
TWO- THREE TO SEE IF THERE'S ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO WOULD LIKE TO BE
ABLE TO STAND- AND VOICE THEIR
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. SEEN
KNOWING STAND WE'RE NOW GOING TO
GO TO A LIVE TELECONFERENCE ON
MR MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE
QUEUE UP ALL INDIVIDUALS WHO MAY
BE OPPOSED TO SB THREE. NOW IF
YOU WHICH SPEAKS OPPOSED TO THIS
LEGISLATION PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
MODERATORS CAN BE QUEUING UP ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS OPPOSED MR
MODERATOR ALTERNATE BACK OVER TO
YOU SIR. THIS YEAR WE HAVE KNOWN
SHOOTING UP AT THIS. THANK YOU
SO MUCH AS A MODERATOR GOING TO
BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE ON
THE START WITH SENATOR LEYVA AND
THEN SENATOR PAN ANY COMMENT
SAID SENATOR LEYVA ON THIS BILL.
THANK YOU SENATOR MCGUIRE I JUST
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING IT FORWARD I THINK THIS
IS A REALLY GOOD TRANSPARENCY
BILL WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THE
MONEY THAT WE ALLOCATE GETS TO
THE RIGHT PARTIES SO JUST THANK
YOU I AM VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THE
BILL. THANK YOU SO MUCH AND
LATER FOR YOUR WORK ON THIS IS
WELL WANT TO TURN OVER TO
SENATOR PAN. THANK YOU AND I TO
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
RAIN THIS BILL FORD APPRECIATE
CENTER RUBIO OF BEING HERE TO
PRESENT THE BILL I DO HAVE A
QUESTION. THAT DERRY HOPE THAT-
YOU'RE ABLE TO ANSWER- SO
CERTAINLY AGE DOES STRONGLY
AGREE WITH THE PURPOSE OF THE
BILL TO INCREASE TRANSPARENCY
CAN YOU PERHAPS ADDRESS IF
YOU'RE ABLE TO. AND I KNOW YOUR
SIR SUBSTITUTING FOR SARAH
CABALLERO- THIS PORTAL IS IT'S
GOING TO REQUIRE ADDITIONAL- I
GUESS- BURDENS FOR REPORTING OR
IS IT USING EXISTING DATA- THAT.
THE SCHOOL DISTRICT'S READY
REPORT SO I JUST WANT TO
UNDERSTAND- WHAT'S THE REPORTING
BURDEN ON THE SCHOOL DISTRICT'S
FOR USING THIS PORTAL I THINK
THE TRANSPARENCY REPORT AND
CERTAINLY WORTH COLLECTING MORE
DATA BUT ALSO MIGHT BE SENSITIVE
TO THE FACT THAT- SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ARE. A PRETTY OVER
BURDEN RIGHT NOW AND- ARE WE
GONNA BE ASKING THEM TO HAVE TO
GENERATE ADDITIONAL REPORTS OR
DO ADDITIONAL DATA COLLECTION OR
TO FULFILL THE REQUIREMENTS OF
THE SAID BILL. THANK YOU US
SENATOR WILL REALLY THIS IS TO
SIMPLIFY AND UNDERSTAND THE
REPORTING BETTER BUT I WILL TURN
IT OVER TO ONE OF THE WITNESSES
THAT CAN ARTICULATE BETTER. HOW
THIS IS GOING TO BE DONE. THANK
YOU I THANK YOU SO MUCH AS A
WE'RE GONNA MAKE SURE THAT THE
MODERATOR AND OUR TECH TEAM IS
ABLE TO QUEUE UP EITHER ROBERT
OR KIERSTEN. ROBERT I'M GOING TO
GO FIRST TO YOU TO BE ABLE TO
ANSWER. THAT SENATOR PANS
QUESTION ROBERT YOU ARE NOW LIVE
BACK IN COMMITTEE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR THE QUESTION- THE
ADDITIONAL- ADDITIONAL WORK THAT
THAT SOME. LOCAL EDUCATION
AGENCIES MIGHT HAVE TO DO IS
THAT THEY WOULD HAVE TO USE THE
STATE ELECTRONIC TEMPLATE FOR IT
EL CAP SO RIGHT NOW EVERY
DISTRICT IN THE STATE HAS TO
WRITE A LOCAL CONTROL
ACCOUNTABILITY PLAN. BUT THEY
TECHNICALLY DON'T HAVE TO USE
THE ELECTRONIC TEMPLATE TO DO
THAT ALMOST ALL JUNE- THIS BILL
BECAUSE IT WOULD TAKE THE
INFORMATION IN THAT ELECTRONIC
TEMPLATE TO POPULATE THE
DATABASE- WOULD REQUIRE THE USE
OF THAT ELECTRONIC TEMPLATE- SO
THAT WOULD BE THE ONE ADDITIONAL
WORKLOAD REQUIREMENT BUT WE
THINK THAT'S RELATIVELY MINIMAL-
THE TO ALEXA AND HAMPLE TOOL HAS
BEEN DESIGNED. TO MAKE IT AS
EASY AS POSSIBLE TO FILL OUT
AND- ALL THE LARGE DISTRICTS AND
ALMOST ALL DISTRICTS IN THE
STATE USE THAT. OKAY AND JUST TO
CLARIFY SIR AT FIFTY IF THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT IS USING
ELECTRONIC TEMPLATE AND THERE'S
NO ADDITIONAL REPORTING BURDEN.
THAT- IS THAT REQUIRED OF THEM.
H. BE ABLE TO TAKE THAT
INFORMATION AND ONE THING YOU
HAVE BEEN APPROVED EL CAPIT
SHOULD TAKE THE DATA FROM THAT-
CAPPING AND LOADED UP I MEAN
THERE WILL HAVE TO BE LIKE. A
MECHANISM TO LOADED- SO THERE
MIGHT BE A BETTER MINIMAL
WORKLOAD ASSOCIATE WITH THAT BUT
IT IT SHOULDN'T BE A DRAMATIC
INCREASE IN WORKLOAD. OKAY ALL
RIGHT NOW I APPRECIATE THAT-
CERTAINLY I HOPE THAT IN ITS
IMPLEMENTATION OBVIOUSLY THIS
BILL ISN'T GONNA SPEAK TO THAT
WOULD THAT WE TRY TO MINIMIZE
THE BURDENS ON. SCHOOL DISTRICTS
IF THEY'RE USING SPECIALLY
DESIGNED ELECTRONIC TEMPLATE-
THAT IT'S GOING TO BE THAT WE
TRIED DESIGN A WAIT SO WE CAN
EXTRACT THE DATA WITHOUT
REQUIRING ADDITIONAL WORK ON
BEHALF SCHOOL DISTRICTS BUT-
APPRECIATE THE BILL AFFECT- WELL
MOVED THE BILL AS APPROPRIATE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH CENTER PEN
WITH THE MOTION ON THE FLOOR
MOTION ON THE FLOOR BY SENATOR
PAN WERE STILL TAKING. ANY
COMMITTEE MEMBER COMMENTS
LOOKING TO SEE IF ANY OF OUR
MEMBERS REMOTELY THAT WOULD LIKE
TO BE ABLE TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
CONVERSATION AND SEEN SHAKING
HEAD AND NO FROM- CENTER DOLLY.
I CENTER CHOI BOGUE ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS. I SHARE THE
SAME BOX AS SENATOR MADE BACK
AND MY REPUBLIC SPREE
TRANSPARENCY BUILT. IN MUCH
NEEDED I THINK. AS WE-
EXPERIENCED LAST YEAR DURING A
LOT OF THE THINGS ARE GOING ON.
ACROSS THE STATE WE HAVE A LOT
OF MACY'S WILL DISTRICTS THAT
HAVE ALREADY BEEN VERY PROACTIVE
AND- I'M MAKING ERRORS ADULT
SERVICES AVAILABLE ONLINE BURKE
WHAT'S YOU. YEAH WITH AVAILABLE
I THINK THIS IS DONE BY SQUARE-
AVAILABLE FOR ALL OUR SINS THIS
YES IT'S WONDERFUL SO THANK YOU
TO THE AUTHOR OF THE VETERAN.
ARE REDUCES. THE BURDEN OF
REPRESENTATIVES. THANK YOU SO
MUCH BETTER CHAIR VERY GREAT IF
TURNS NOBODY COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE EITHER REMOTELY OR
HEARING HEARING ROOM CENTER
REALLY WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU- SENATORS AS YOU KNOW
WE'VE BEEN PRIORITIZING
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION WITH
HISTORIC INVESTMENTS ADDING TO
ELEVEN POINT FIVE. BILLION
DOLLARS FOR STUDENTS ACROSS THE
STATE AND I CAN ALSO CONCUR
WITH- BOB MRS FARRELL AND THAT
EVEN AS A TEACHER A FORMER
ADMINISTRATOR AND EVEN COMMUNITY
MEMBER JUST TRYING TO UNDERSTAND
THESE REPORTS ARE VERY.
COMPLICATED VERY DIFFICULT AND I
BELIEVE THAT THE LEGISLATURE
MUST NOW DEPLOYED BETTER
TRACKING SYSTEMS A TRANSPARENCY
AND ACCOUNTABILITY
ACCOUNTABILITY SYSTEMS AT TWO
FIFTY WORTH BE A CRITICAL
INVESTMENTS ARE I THINK OUR
STUDENTS ARE TOO IMPORTANT NOT
TO AND I THINK THIS IS JUST A
SIMPLE ACCOUNTABILITY
TRANSPARENCY MEASURE AND I ASK
FOR YOUR RIFLE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SO MUCH CENTER RUBY ON
BEHALF OF THE CENTRE COVER GIRL
THE MOTION ON THE FLOOR INSIDE
CENTER PAN THE MOTION IS TO PASS
BUT FIRST BE RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
THAT AND SHE CONSULTANT IF YOU
CAN PLEASE RESTATE THE MOTION
CALL THE ROLL. FILE ITEM NUMBER
ONE SB THREE MOTION IS A TO PASS
BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
SENATOR LEYVA. BY CENTER LEYVA
HI SB THREE. LEYVA HI SENATOR-
TROUBLED SENATOR CHERUB WORLD SB
THREE. A TROUBLED BY CORTESE.
ALL RIGHT COURTESY I TALLY
GALLEY SB THREE BY. TWENTY ONE
MORE TIME AT CENTER DAILY DO YOU
MIND REPEATING THAT I APOLOGIZE
. DALLY SB THREE. I THANK YOU
SIR KELLY HI GLAZER. HI GLAZER
AYE MCGUIRE. MCGUIRE AYE PAN HI
CAN I SEVEN ZERO BY THAT IS A
SEVEN ZERO VOTE THAT BILL IS OUT
AND WE'RE CLOSING THE ROLE THANK
YOU SO MUCH AND RUBIO THANK YOU
TO OUR MEMBERS FOR THE
ENGAGEMENT LETTERS IN GENERAL
COMMITTEE WERE NOW MOVING ON TO
OUR SECOND DAUGHTER FIVE TODAY
ON OUR DOCKET THIS IS SENATE
BILL TWO EIGHTY SIX THAT
SENTIMENT HAS BEEN WORKING. WITH
THE AN ORANGE COUNTY DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION ON THIS ISSUE THAT
CENTER MINUTES CAN BE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY TODAY
CENTER MAIN WE WELCOME USER
COMMITTEE YOU ARE NOW LIVE ON S.
B. TWO EIGHTY SIX. PLEASE
PROCEED. I COULD SHARE MEMBERS
STAFFERS ALL I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR WORK
ON THIS BILL AND I. WILL BE
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS
SUGGESTED ON PAGE THREE THE
ANALYSIS. TO CLARIFY THAT S. B.
TWO EIGHTY SIX APPLIES ONLY TO
ELECTIONS FOR SEATS ON THE
ORANGE COUNTY BOARD OF
EDUCATION. DUE TO TIME
CONSTRAINTS THESE AMENDMENTS
WILL BE MADE IN THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. NOW
THIS BILL SB TWO EIGHTY SIX IS
BASED ON A SIMPLE PROPOSITION.
ONE THAT'S BEEN RECOGNIZE
THROUGH ALMOST ALL OF THE STATE.
BOARD OF EDUCATION AT THE COUNTY
LEVEL ISA VERY IMPORTANT
GOVERNMENTAL BODY. AND AS SUCH
ELECTIONS FOR THE SEATS SHOULD
TAKE PLACE IN NOVEMBER WITH THE
FALL ELECTORATE RATHER THAN IN
THE PRIMARY- WITH LOWER TURN OUT
AS IS THE CASE IN ORANGE COUNTY.
AS WE KNOW TURNOUT IS FAR FAR
LOWER IN PRIMARY ELECTIONS AND
GENERAL ELECTIONS. FOR EXAMPLE
IN 202-800-8018 THOUSAND ORANGE
COUNTY VOTERS VOTE IN THE
PRIMARY. AS OPPOSED TO ONE POINT
FIVE FIVE MILLION VOTERS IN THE
GENERAL ELECTION BY NEARLY TWO
FOLD INCREASE. I'VE TALKED TO
MANY VOTERS IN MY DISTRICT HAVE
EXPRESSED FRUSTRATION OR
CONFUSION ABOUT THE FACT THAT
THEY WERE NOT ABLE TO VOTE FOR
THEIR BOARD OF EDUCATION RACE.
SIMPLY BECAUSE THEY DID NOT VOTE
IN THE PRIMARY ELECTION. COUNTY
BOARD OF ED SERVE CRITICAL
FUNCTIONS IN OUR STATE. BY
PROVIDING OVERSIGHT OF SCHOOL
DISTRICTS EDUCATING STUDENTS
WITH SPECIAL NEEDS AND PROVIDING
DIRECT SERVICES TO SCHOOL
DISTRICTS. MORE THAN MEMBERS
ALSO PLAY AN INFLUENTIAL AND
POWERFUL ROLE IN THEIR OUTREACH
EFFORTS TO THE COMMUNITY.
PARENTS AND STUDENTS BOTH IN
THEIR DISTRICTS BUT ALSO
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. THAT'S WHY
IT'S IMPERATIVE THAT WE MAKE
EVERY EFFORT TO GET MORE VOTERS
ENGAGED IN THESE CRITICAL LOCAL
GOVERNING BOARDS. ORANGE
COUNTY'S PRACTICE OF HOLDING ITS
BOARD OF EDUCATIONAL ACTIONS IN
THE PRIMARY. IS AN OUT LIAR
COMPARED TO ALMOST EVERY OTHER
COUNTY ACROSS THE STATE. FROM
THE COUNTY BOARD THE DEAD HAD
CANDIDATE ELECTIONS IN TWENTY
TWENTY FORTY TWO OF THEM APPEAR
ON THE NOVEMBER GENERAL ELECTION
BALLOT. ONLY FIVE INCLUDING
ORANGE COUNTY HOW COUNTY
ELECTIONS FOR THESE BOARDS. ON
THE PRIMARY BALLOT IN TWENTY
TWENTY. NOW PLEASE TURN OUT
DIFFERENCES. PRIME RANGING
ELECTIONS EFFECTIVELY
DISENFRANCHISE MANY VOTERS IN
ORANGE COUNTY NEARLY HALF OF ALL
VOTERS IN TWENTY TWENTY. AND THE
PARTICULARLY PRONOUNCED AMONG
RACIAL AND ETHNIC MINORITIES.
YOUNG PEOPLE AND LOW PROPENSITY
VOTERS. IT IS WELL DOCUMENTED
THAT LIMITED ENGLISH PROFICIENT
VOTERS. YOUNGER VOTERS BETWEEN
THE AGES OF EIGHTEEN AND THIRTY
FIVE. AN AFRICAN AMERICAN ASIAN
AMERICAN AND LATINO VOTERS VOTE
AT MUCH HIGHER RATES IN GENERAL
ELECTIONS BEEN IN PRIMARY
ELECTIONS. SB TWO EIGHTY SIX
WOULD REQUIRE THAT ELECTIONS THE
ORANGE COUNTY BOARD OF
EDUCATION. BE CONSOLIDATED WITH
THE STATEWIDE GENERAL ELECTION
IN NOVEMBER INSTEAD OF THE
PRIMARY ELECTION. AND THAT WOULD
APPLY THE SAME ELECTION TIME
LINES CURRENTLY IN PLACE FOR THE
MAJORITY COUNTY BOARD OF
EDUCATION. TO ORANGE COUNTY. SB
TWO EIGHTY SIX WOULD INCREASE
VOTER PARTICIPATION. IN THE
ORANGE COUNTY BOARD DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION OFFICE THE COUNTY
BOARD OF EDUCATION ELECTIONS.
AND REDUCE VOTER CONFUSION BY
CREATING UNIFORMITY AROUND THE
TIMING OF THESE IMPORTANT
ELECTIONS. ONLINE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL I HAVE
ELIZABETH WARREN PARKER. PAST
PRESIDENT OF THE ORANGE COUNTY
SCHOOL BOARD'S ASSOCIATION. AND
THERESA RAY CHAIR OF THE
SUPPORTERS OF PUBLIC EDUCATION
ONE COUNTY. THANK YOU SO MUCH
CENTER INCREASE YOUR WORK ON
THIS AT LEAST IN GENERAL CAN BE
GOING TO OUR FIRST SET LEAD
WITNESSES WILL BE. PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY WE'RE GONNA BE GOING TO
DOCTOR DORN PARKER PAST PRESENT
ORANGE COUNTY SCHOOL BOARD
ASSOCIATION. MISTER PARKER YOU
HAVE TWO MINUTES I'LL GIVE YOU A
THIRTY SECOND PROMPT YOU ARE NOW
LIVE IN EDUCATION COMMITTEE
PLEASE PROCEED. THANK YOU AS I
HAVE SERVED THIRTY TWO YEARS ON
THAT CORNY BOARD OF EDUCATION
MYSELF. I ACKNOWLEDGE HOW LITTLE
IS UNDERSTOOD ARE KNOWN ABOUT
THE CRITICAL LEADERSHIP ROLE.
ORANGE COUNTY BOARD OF EDUCATION
SERVE WITHIN THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC EDUCATION SYSTEM. EXCEPT
FOR JUVENILE JUSTICE SCHOOLS
COMMUNITY SCHOOLS. THESE BOARDS
ARE VERY DIFFERENT
RESPONSIBILITIES FROM THOSE UP
LOCAL SCHOOL BOARDS AS DEFINED
IN AT CONSTRUCTION. TEN FOURTEEN
TEN FORTY TWO. THE ONLY ELECTED
BOARD TO FOCUS ON THE STUDENT
ENROLLED IN JUVENILE AND
COMMUNITY SCHOOL OUR COUNTY
pIN THE SCHOOLS ARE OUR MOST
VULNERABLE THEY CAN INCLUDE A
HIGHER PERCENTAGE OF HOMELESS
FOSTER YOU. L. G. B. T. Q. PLUS.
CHILDREN KICKED OUT OR DROPPED
OUT THEREFORE THEY NEED TRUSTEE
TO PRIORITIZE YOUR EDUCATIONAL.
SOCIAL AND EMOTIONAL ME. HERE
ARE MOST AT PROMISED TO HAVE A
LEAD TO BLOW IMAGE TRUSTEE HYPER
FOCUSED ON THEIR WELL BEING. THE
HIGHEST NUMBER OF VOTERS NEED TO
ELECT THEM IN ORANGE COUNTY IN
PARTICULAR MOVING THE ELECTION
FROM JUNE PRIMARIES TO
NOVEMBER'S GENERAL ELECTION WILL
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF VOTERS
SELECTING THE TRUSTEES FOR THESE
CHILDREN. THE SIGNIFICANT NUMBER
OF THESE CHILDREN LIVE IN
TRADITIONALLY DISENFRANCHISED
COMMUNITIES. AND MANY AND ROLE
IN THE ORANGE COUNTY BOARD OF
EDUCATION SCHOOL. THE MORE
VOTERS TO UNDERSTAND THEIR
CHALLENGES AND LIVED EXPERIENCES
THE MORE LIKELY THEY WILL ELECT
EDUCATIONAL LEADERS TO
UNDERSTAND AND PRIORITIZE THEIR
NEEDS. WHEN I BEGAN MY TENURE IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY TWO ON THIS
ORANGE COUNTY BOARD OF
EDUCATION. NONE OF US
APPRECIATED HOW MUCH IT MATTERS
WHO VOTED IN THREE. THE
IMPORTANCE OF THESE TRUSTEES IS
NOW UNDENIABLE AS MAYA ANGELO SO
ELOQUENTLY SAID DO THE BEST WE
CAN. UNTIL WE KNOW BETTER THAN
WE KNOW BETTER WE BETTER DO
BETTER WE NOW KNOW BETTER THIRTY
MUST HELP THESE CHILDREN B. C.
B. ELECTED EDUCATIONAL
LEADERSHIP. THEY DESERVE AND
MOVED THE ORANGE COUNTY BOARD OF
EDUCATIONALISTS FROM THE PRIMARY
IN JUNE TO THE GENERAL IN THE
PAST. THANK YOU THANK YOU SO
MUCH ARE TO REALLY GREAT OF YOUR
PARTICIPATION TODAY. ALL RIGHT
LAYS IN GENERAL CAN BE GOING TO
OUR SECOND AND FINAL LEAD
WITNESS THAT'S MISTER RAY SHE'S
THE CHAIR AND SUPPORTERS OF
PUBLIC EDUCATION ORANGE COUNTY
COMMITTEE. MYSTERY WELCOME TO
COMMITTEE THE FLOOR IS YOURS YOU
HAVE TWO MINUTES AND I'LL GIVE
YOU. THIRTY SECOND PROMPT.
PLEASE PROCEED. BUT MORE
SENATORS AND THANK YOU FOR WHAT
YOU'RE DOING TODAY. I'M RETIRED
HIGH SCHOOL TEACHER OF FOR
DECADES AND UNION PRESIDENT WITH
EXTENSIVE EXPERIENCE
COLLABORATING WITH MY LOCAL
SCHOOL BOARD. I CURRENTLY ARE
THE COUNTY WIDE NETWORK. YEAH
YOUR ATTENTION OF. A LITTLE
BEING. A MYSTERY WE'RE GONNA
HAVE YOU DESPISE FOR ONE MOMENT
WE HAVE A LINE THAT IS A LIVE
ORGAN MUSIC MYSTERY WE APOLOGIZE
. TWENTY MAKE SURE THAT THE LINE
IS NEEDED CORRECT IS THAT IT
RIGHT THUMBS UP. YES THANK YOU
SO MUCH MYSTERY I DON'T HAVE THE
START OVER IF YOU DON'T MIND
PLEASE I START FROM THE
BEGINNING WE APOLOGIZE ABOUT
THAT YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES. AND
THE TIME WILL START NOW. GOOD
MORNING SENATORS THANK YOU FOR
WHAT YOU'RE DOING. TODAY AND ALL
THE TIME- ABSOLUTELY SUPPORTING
EDUCATION. I'M A RETIRED HIGH
SCHOOL TEACHER OF FOR DECADES
AND UNION PRESIDENT WITH
EXTENSIVE EXPERIENCE
COLLABORATING WITH MY LOCAL
SCHOOL BOARD I CURRENTLY CHAIR
THE COUNTY WIDE NETWORK
SUPPORTERS OF PUBLIC EDUCATION
O. C. FOLLOWING THE ACTIONS OF
LOCAL SCHOOL BOARDS AND ORANGE
COUNTY BOARD OF EDUCATION.
SUPPORT MOVING THE ELECTION FOR
THE ORANGE COUNTY BOARD OF THE
TRUSTEES FROM JUNE TO NOVEMBER
TO PROVIDE BETTER REPRESENTATION
FOR ALL TWENTY NINE LOCAL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND MORE IMPORTANTLY
FOR THE STUDENTS SERVED BY THE
ORANGE COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. BUILDING FOR TRUSTEES
IN NOVEMBER EMPHASIZES THE
IMPORTANCE OF THAT BOARDS WORK
CURRENTLY THIS RACES JUSTIN OUT
ONTO A PRIMARY AND THEREFORE
SEEMS INSIGNIFICANT GET THIS
ELECTION IS A ONE AND DONE IT IS
THEREFORE MORE IMPORTANT THAN A
PRIMARY ELECTION. BASICALLY IT
COMES DOWN TO THE FACT THAT MORE
PEOPLE VOTE IN NOVEMBER GENERAL
ELECTIONS AND THE JUNE PRIMARIES
IN 202048% MORE ORANGE COUNTY
VOTERS PARTICIPATED IN THE
NOVEMBER GENERAL THAN IN THE
JUNE PRIMARY AT THE DEMOCRACY WE
WANT THE HIGHEST NUMBER OF
ELIGIBLE VOTERS TO PARTICIPATE
IN ELECTIONS. GOD VOTER
PARTICIPATION IS PARTICULARLY
IMPORTANT IN THE OCP ELECTION
BECAUSE IT IS DECIDED BY A
PLURALITY NOT A MAJORITY.
CURRENTLY SOME TRUSTEES EARNED
ONLY 33% OF THE VOTE YET THEY
MAKE DECISIONS THAT AFFECT OUR
MOST VULNERABLE CHILDREN
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTY THIRTY
SECONDS PRESIDENT ROOSEVELT.
THAT'S THE HIGHEST NUMBER OF
VOTERS POSSIBLE PARTICIPATE AND
OCB ELECTIONS WHICH ARE DECIDED
MERELY BY PLURALITY. MOVING THE
ELECTIONS IN NOVEMBER WOULD
ENSURE MORE FAIR RESULTS PLEASE
VOTE TO APPROVE SB TWO EIGHTY
SIX THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR PARTICIPATION- AND
POWERFUL NUMBERS THAT WERE JUST
RECITED GRATEFUL FOR THAT.
ALRIGHT LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
WE'VE HEARD FROM OUR TO LEAD
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT WE'RE NOT
GOING TO SEE IF THERE IS ANYONE
IN SUPPORT OF. THE S. B. TWO
EIGHTY SIX IN ROOM FORTY TWO-
THREE SEEN KNOWN STAND WERE NOT
TO BE GOING TO OUR LIVE
TELECONFERENCE LINE WE WELCOME
ANY AND ALL PARTICIPATION TODAY.
WE'RE GONNA CHECK IN WITH THE
MODERATOR MISTER MODERATOR IF
YOU CAN PLEASE QUEUE UP ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS IN SUPPORT OF
S. B. TWO EIGHTY SIX NOW. THANK
YOU MISS CHAIR IF YOU WISH IN
SUPPORT THIS LIST PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE DO
HAVE ONE IN Q. WILL GO UP TO ONE
THIRTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOU ARE
LIGHTING COMMITTEE LINE THIRTY
PLEASE PROCEED. ALL RIGHT MISTER
MODERATOR LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. AND WE HAVE NO
ONE ELSE IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
MODERATOR WE APPRECIATE THAT
LAYS IN GERMAN WE'RE NOW GOING
TO BE GOING TO THOSE WHO MAY BE
OPPOSED TO SB TWO EIGHTY SIX. WE
DO NOT HAVE A LEAD OPPOSITION
WITNESS ON FILE HERE TODAY WE
ARE GOING TO CHECK IN TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE IN ROOM FORTY TWO
OR THREE WOULD LIKE TO BE A TO
SPEAK ON THIS BILL. SEEN NO ONE
STAND WE'RE NOT GONNA BE GOING
TO OUR LIVE TELECONFERENCE LINE
MISTER MODERATOR WE'RE GOING TO
ASK YOU TO PLEASE ASK ALL
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE IN
OPPOSITION OF SB TWO EIGHTY SIX
TO BE QUEUED UP. NOW. MISTER
CHAIRMAN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
UP. IN OPPOSE THIS LEGISLATION
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. SURE WE DON'T HAVE
ANYONE SHOWING UP AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
MODERATOR WERE VERY GRATEFUL FOR
THAT WE'RE GOING TO BE BRINGING
IT BACK TO COMMITTEE TO THOSE
ARE PARTICIPATING REMOTELY AS
WELL AS IN PERSON WE'RE GONNA
START WITH SENATOR LEYVA AND
THEN GO TO SENATOR PAN. CENTER
LEYVA. THANK YOU SENATOR MCGUIRE
I JUST WANT TO THANK CENTERMAN
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD I
THINK IT'S A GREAT BILL TO HELP
INCREASE VOTER TURNOUT. AND IT
THE MORE PEOPLE WHO PARTICIPATE
IN THE PROCESS BETTER SO THANK
YOU SENTIMENT THANK YOU SO MUCH
. MADAM SENATOR WE'RE NOT GONNA
GO TO SENATOR PAN THEY WERE
GONNA GO TO VICE CHAIR UNTIL A
BOGEY RIGHT AFTER CENTER PAN
CENTER PAN PLEASE PROCEED WITH
MOVE THE BILL FOR THE MOTION ON
THE FLOOR BY SENATOR PAN. WE'RE
GOING TO GO NOW TO VICE CHAIR OF
CHOI BOGUE MADE BY SHARE THE
FLOOR IS YOURS AND GOING TO GO
TO SENATOR GLAZERS SO AT
MIDNIGHT HERE PLEASE PROCEED.
THERE ARE A LOT- REQUIRE I'M IN
YOU CENTER MEMBER BE HERE THIS
JEOPARDY MORNING. I DO HAVE A
QUESTION HERE IS THAT- EXIST LAW
OF JOURNEY TOWARDS IMAGE TO
CHANGE VERY MUCH EITHER THE
STATE WIDE DAY RIGHT CHEN OR
MUNICIPAL ELECTION. THAT'S A
KNOWLEDGE HAS THE COUNTY OF THE
EVER DISCUSS THIS LOCALLY OR HAS
ANY AB YOU GET CHIU BEFORE THE
COUNTY BOARD OF EDUCATION.
INTERMIN ON THE VICE CHAIR IS
QUITE PLEASE FOR. AT YOU SO MUCH
FOR THE CALL- VICE CHAIR WHICH
OF A- YOU KNOW TO MINOR. THIS OP
HAS BEEN AVAILABLE AS YOU
POINTED FOR DECADE AND YET HAVE
NOT SEEN ANY. I'M NOT A
POLITICAL BUT I THAT YOU KNOW I
. FOLKS WHO. BENEFIT FROM
TURNOUT MAY NOT IN MAY NOT BE IN
THEIR INTERESTS TO WANT TO- I
HAVE ELECTIONS THAT HAVE FULL
TURNOUT AND SO- IN THIS BILL IS
AN ATTEMPT TO KIND OF SHAKE UP
THE STATUS QUO AND REALLY BRING
IT IN LINE BRING ORANGE COUNTY
IN LINE WITH THE REST OF STATE
AS I POINTED OUT. ORANGE COUNTY
REALLY IS AN OUT LIAR HERE AND
WHILE I DID THINK ABOUT DOING A
STATEWIDE SOLUTION- FOR THIS
BILL IT SEEMS UNNECESSARY GIVEN
THAT AND IT'S NOT EVEN MAJORITY
I THINK LIKE 90% AS I MENTIONED
OF. BOARDS OF EDUCATION ALREADY
HOLD THEIR- ELECTIONS IN
NOVEMBER SO- THIS IS REALLY AN
ATTEMPT TO HARMONIZE THAT THAT
DISTRICTS THAT PROBLEM THAT
CLEARLY THE BOARD EDUCATION
ITSELF IS NOT IN YET TAKEN ANY
STEPS TO TRY TO ADDRESS. THANK
YOU CENTERMAN MATTER BY SHARING
YOUR OWN TIME. SO IN OTHER WORDS
IT HAS. BEEN BROUGHT UP TO THE
TO THE BOARD. FOR CONSIDERATION
HOUSING. THE WHERE NOBODY THE
PUBLIC AS FAR THIS FORWARD TO
THAT THE MORE. GENERATION I
DON'T KNOW THAT ANSWER IF I. AM
SAFE AND- WAS THAT YOU QUESTION
. PART TIME SORRY. BUT I SORRY I
DIDN'T TO CUT YOU OFF I. I WAS
JUST WONDERING WHETHER OR NOT HE
- D. HAD ANYONE COME TO THE
BOARD AND ASK FOR INSPIRATION UP
WHEN THE BUILDING SHOOK HER
SUPPORT WORKER WHO WILL OF
COURSE CHANGE HAVE THAT BEEN
INTEREST LOCALLY BY LOCAL
CONSTITUENTS. MY UNDER BUT I
DON'T WANT TO COMMIT TO AN
ANSWER I DON'T KNOW FULLY HI AND
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION VICE
CHAIR I EASE THAT THERE HAVE
BEEN CONSTITUENTS WOULD HAVE
BROUGHT THIS TO BOARD MEMBERS-
AS A SUGGESTION BUT I DON'T KNOW
THE STATUS OF ANY EFFORTS TO IT
WHETHER THIS WAS CONSIDERED
FORMALLY OR NOT I SOMETHING I
CAN HAVE MY STAFF LOOK INTO AND
GET BACK TO YOU. MINIMIZE SHARE
OF WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU
HAVE COMPLETED YOUR REMARKS ARE
YOU COMFORTABLE WITH THAT
RESPONSE MINIMIZED HERE BEFORE
WE MOVED CENTER LASER. HI I JUST
WANT TO MAKE ONE LAST COMMENT IS
SOMEONE WHO TRULY BELIEVES LOCAL
CONTROL IN TRYING TO ADDRESS
ISSUES LOCAL THESE FIRST BEFORE
MOVING FORWARD IN THE STATE
RIGHT. ONE SIZE FITS ALL- I
EIGHT YOU KNOW I AND I I'M A
LITTLE CONCERNED ABOUT THAT BUT
I WOULD LOVE TO HEAR MORE ABOUT
WHETHER OR NOT. IT HAD BEING
BROUGHT TO THE BOARD FOR
CONSIDERATION AND WHETHER OR NOT
IT HAD BEEN TURNED DOWN WHAT
WHAT WHAT WHAT HAPPENS AFTER
THAT- LOCALLY FIRST- YOU KNOW IF
IT'S SOMETHING THAT THE LOCAL
CONSTITUENTS. ADVOCATE IT WORK
ADVOCATING FOR- WITH YOUR LOCAL
WORK. THANK YOU SENATOR NAY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH READING BY
CHAIR CENTER NEED YOUR RESPONSE
TO. THE VICE TO IF YOU COULD
LOOPY CENTRE LEYVA THE CHIEF
CONSULTANT FOR BURKE. ON JUSTIN
SURE THAT THERE IN THE LOOP ON
THAT ANSWER IS WELL THANK YOU
NOW TO. MY ROOM FORTY TWO OR
THREE INTERNET OVER
DISINTEGRATED. THANK YOU- ACTING
CHAIRMAN CHOIR- FOR THOSE WHO I
HAVE WORKED WITH ME IN THE PAST
THEY KNOW THAT I HAVE A-
PARTICULAR- ATTENTION FOCUSED ON
LOCAL CONTROL THAT'S A- RIDING
OUT PRINCIPLE- AND IN THIS CASE
WE HAVE A- CENTER FROM ORANGE
COUNTY WHO'S ASKING FOR THIS
CHANGE FOR. HIS PARTICULAR
SCHOOL DISTRICT AND IT'S UP FOR
ME A COMPELLING. CASE THAT
BECAUSE THIS BILL WILL BE HEARD
NEXT IN SENATE ELECTIONS I'M
GONNA SUPPORT MOVING THE BILL
FORWARD TODAY DON'T WANT TO
PRECLUDE THE- ROBUST DISCUSSION
WE MAY HAVE ON IT WITH US. THE
GAUGE OF THE PUBLIC AND OTHERS
TOMORROW AND I WOULD JUST NOTE
THAT FOR THE RECORD. I THINK SO
MUCH WELL SAID THE CENTER GLAZER
THANK YOU SO MUCH. I WOULD LIKE
TO BE ABLE TO DO A LAST CALL
LAST CALL FOR COMMENTS LAST CALL
FOR COMMENTS QUESTIONS. FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS SINGER DOLLY
AND OR CENTER CORTESE LAST CALL
SEEN NOTHING FROM CENTER CORTESE
NOTHING FROM CENTER DOLLY. THANK
YOU SO MUCH MEMBERS FOR THE
ROBUST DISCUSSION BUT WE'RE NOT
GOING TO GO TO CENTERMAN FOR THE
CLOSE. THANK YOU COLLEAGUES- AND
THANK YOU CHAIR SB TWO EIGHTY
SIX IS A LOCAL ELECTIONS BILL
THAT WOULD PROMOTE GREATER VOTER
PARTICIPATION IN A VERY
IMPORTANT ELECTION FOR COUNTY
BOARD OF BAD. AND WOULD%
ELIMINATE A LOT OF UNNECESSARY
CONFUSION AROUND THE TIMING OF
ELECTIONS I THAT REALLY HAS
IMPACTED VOTERS HERE IT HAS NO
FORMAL OPPOSITION AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SO AND SO MUCH
CENTERMAN FOR ALL YOUR WORK- AS
WELL APPRECIATE THAT. WE HAVE A
MOTION ON THE FLOOR BY CENTER
PAN THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT
FIRST BE RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON ELECTIONS. IN
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENTS MADAM
CHIEF CONSULTANT IF YOU CAN
PLEASE RESTATE THE MOTION AND
CALL THE ROLL. FILE ITEM NUMBER
TWO S. B. TWO EIGHTY SIX. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
ELECTIONS. EXCUSE ME ELECTIONS
AND CONSTITUTIONAL. AMENDMENTS
SENATOR LEYVA. CENTER LEYVA. SB
TWO. SIX HI. LEYVA I OTOBO.
EDITOR CHOKO S. EACH YEAR. SEVEN
ZERO. I'M IN MY CHAIR DO YOU
MIND REPEATING THAT ONE MORE
TIME DO APOLOGIZE. ABSOLUTELY
SENATOR SEIZE YOUR TROUBLE AT
TWO EIGHT SIX NO THANK YOU SO
MUCH OCTOBER NO COURTESY HI FOR
TWO I. DALY. GALLY S. B. TWO
EIGHT SIX NO TELLING NOW GLAZER
HI GLAZER HI MCGUIRE AYE MCGUIRE
AYE PAN. AM I. FIVE TWO THANK
YOU SO MUCH YOU THAT IS A FIVE
TWO VOTE FIVE TO FIND ABOUT THE
BILL IS OUT WE'RE CLOSING THE
ROLE THANK YOU SO MUCH MEMBERS
AND REALLY APPRECIATE THOSE WHO
PARTICIPATE REMOTELY DOING THAT
EXTRA STEP WERE REALLY GRATEFUL
FOR YOUR ACCEPTANCE OF THAT IS
WELL LAYS IN GERMAN OF COMMITTEE
WOULD LIKE TO CALL A LITTLE BIT
OF AN AUDIBLE WE HAVE A
COLLEAGUE THAT HAS SOME TIME
CONSTRAINTS TODAY. WE DO KNOW
THAT WE HAVE CENTER PORTANTINO
AS WELL CENTER ALLEN FOR THAT
RIGHT NOW READY TO ROLL BUT
WE'RE GOING TO ASK IF IT'S
ALRIGHT WITH COMMITTEE THAT WE
ALLOW SENATOR ROTH WHO IS FILE
ITEM FIVE DB TO PROCEED NOW THAT
HE DOES HAVE SOME TIME
CONSTRAINTS SO WE'D LIKE TO
WELCOME CENTER ROTH TO BE ABLE
TO PLEASE COME FORWARD ON S. B.
SIX TWO TWO WE REALLY GRATEFUL
TO BOTH CENTER PORTANTINO IS
WELL SENATOR- ALLEN FOR THEIR
PATIENTS CENTER ROTH WE WELCOME
YOU TO COMMITTEE THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR BEING YOU'RE HAPPY NEW
YEAR TO FLOOR IS YOURS. ON SB
SIX TWO TWO. FOR YOU THANK YOU
FOR- COMMITTEE MEMBERS THIS ON.
YOU YES SIR PLEASE- COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THANK YOU CALLING THANK
YOU FOR PATIENCE THE BILL US
THIS BILL ESTABLISHES A PER TO
TUITION ASSISTANCE TO ELIGIBLE
INDIVIDUALS SPECIFICALLY
PROBATION OFFICERS PURSUING
POSTGRADUATE DEGREES WHO ARE
CURRENTLY EMPLOYED BY THE
PROBATION DEPARTMENT SERVING USE
AND ALSO THOSE WHO COMMIT TO
SEEKING EMPLOYMENT IN A
PROBATION DEPARTMENT I RECOGNIZE
THERE IS A LACK OF SPECIFICITY
WITH REGARD TO THE- EDUCATIONAL
PROGRAMS AUTHORIZED AS POINTED
OUT IN YOUR- ANALYSIS AND SHOULD
THE BILL PASS OUT OF THIS
COMMITTEE TODAY. I INTEND TO
AMEND THE BILL TO NARROW THE
SCOPE OF GRADUATE DEGREES
ELIGIBLE FOR TUITION ASSISTANCE
TO PROVIDE THAT SPECIFICITY.
PRIOR TO MOVING THE BILL TO THE
FLOOR. THE SEMI CENTER OFFERING
GRATEFUL FOR THAT COMMITMENT
THAT LAYS IN GENERAL WE HAVE ONE
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS GOING TO BE
OUR LEAD WITNESS AND THAT'S
DANIEL SANCHEZ. SHE'S A
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR- FOR THE
CHIEF PROBATION OFFICERS OF THE
GREAT STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE'RE
GOING TO TURN IT OVER TO ME
SANCHEZ NOW- AND ASK HER TO
PLEASE PROCEED- TWO MINUTES I'LL
GIVE YOU A THIRTY SECOND PROMPT.
MISSING CHANCE WE WELCOME YOU TO
COMMITTEE. YEAH ALL RIGHT. MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT MESSAGES
LINE- SHE TERMINATED THAT SO
HERE'S WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO. AND
WE'RE VERY FLEXIBLE HERE INEDUCATION COMMITTEE WE'RE GONNA
COME BACK TO MS SANCHEZ BUT
WE'RE GONNA CONTINUE TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH. THAT BOTH SUPPORT
AS WELL AS- OPPOSITION TESTIMONY
SO WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO NOW IS
WE'RE GOING TO OPEN UP OUR-
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF SB SIX
TO. SEE IF THERE'S AN INDIVIDUAL
HERE ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE WHO'D
LIKE TO BE AN ISSUE. I'D SAY A
FEW WORDS HEARING SEEN KNOWN
WE'RE NOT GONNA BE GOING TO OUR
REMOTE. TELECONFERENCING LINE
WE'RE GOING TO ASK THE MODERATOR
DEPUTE PLEASE QUEUE UP ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS IN SUPPORT OF
SB SIX TWO TWO NOW. IN LAYS DOWN
WHEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK OF
SUPPORT OF THIS LEGISLATION
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. IN THIS CHAIR WE
DON'T HAVE ANYONE SHOWING UP AT
THIS TIME ALL RIGHT THANK YOU SO
MUCH- THE CHIEF CONSULTANT I
THINK IS ME WORKING ON THE
CRICKETS SOUNDTRACK AT A WE-
HEAR THE SILENCE SO THERE WE GO.
THANK YOU SO MUCH- MISTER
MODERATOR WERE NOW GOING TO BE
SEEN. IF THERE'S ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION SB SIX TWO TWO BUT WE
DO NOT HAVE A LEAD OPPOSITION
WITNESS OR WITNESSES ON FILE. SO
NOW WE'RE GONNA GO TO THOSE WHO
MAY BE OPPOSED TO SIX TWO TWO IN
ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE. SEEN NO
ONE RIGHTS ARE NOT GOING TO BE
GOING TO OUR LIVE TELECONFERENCE
LINE. MISTER MODERATOR CAN YOU
PLEASE QUEUE UP ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHO MAY BE IN OPPOSITION TO SB
SIX TWO TWO NOW. THANK YOU
MISTER IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK AND
OPPOSED TO THIS LEGISLATION
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT
THIS TIME. THE MEASURE WE HAVE
NO ENTRY BUT THIS TIME TO
APPRECIATE THAT MR MODERATOR.
CENTER CORTESE HAS SAID HE WOULD
LIKE TO BE ABLE TO HEAR FROM THE
SAME CHANCE AND MISTER CORTESE
WE GOTCHA. SO WE'RE NOT GONNA BE
GOING TO OUR LIVE TELECONFERENCE
LINE DANIEL SANCHEZ IS LIVE WITH
US SHE IS THE LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTOR FOR THE CHIEF PROBATION
OFFICERS- CALIFORNIA.SHE IS
GOING TO LEAD SUPPORT WITNESS ON
BEHALF OF SIX TWO TO MAKE
CHANGES WE WELCOME YOU THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR CALLING BACK IN. TWO
MINUTES AND WE'LL GIVE YOU A
THIRTY SECOND PROMPT PLEASE
PROCEDURE LIVE- GOOD MORNING
SHARE AN AD SENATORS THANK YOU
SO MUCH- AND APPRECIATE THE
TIME. THAT YOU JUST BRIEFLY I
WANTED TO FIRST OF COURSE THANK
AT SENATOR ROB FOR LEADING ON
THIS IMPORTANT ISSUES- IMPORTANT
ISSUE FOR PROBATION APARTMENTS
AND THE PROVISION APARTMENTS ARE
AT FEDERALLY FEDERALLY
RECOGNIZED A TITLE FOR EACH
ELIGIBLE ENTITY. WE SERVE FOSTER
YOUTH IN A VERY HOLISTIC MANNER
BY PROVIDING SERVICES RELATED TO
PLACEMENT FAMILY SUPPORT FOR.
ACCESSING BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SERVICES INDEPENDENT LIVING
EDUCATIONAL GOALS AND MANY OTHER
SERVICES. AN APARTMENT- HOLDEN
IN THE HIGHEST REGARD BEING ABLE
TO HIRE THE MOST QUALIFIED AND
DEDICATED PROFESSIONALS TO
SUPPORT IN A RICH ALLIES OF
YOUTH THAT WE SERVE. ORTING
EDUCATION RECRUITMENT FOR
COLLEGE GRADUATES TO ENTER INTO
A CAREER IN PROBATION PUBLIC
SERVICE HOPE THE FOSTER PROOF
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT AND
ENHANCE THE SKILL SETS AND WE
CERTAINLY KNOW- THAT THAT
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT AND
SKILL SETS DIRECTLY SUPPORT THE
DELIVERY OF SERVICES TO YOUTH
AND THEIR FAMILIES- THIS BILL I
THINK IMPORTANTLY IS ABLE TO
DRAW DOWN. ON FEDERAL TITLE
FORTY DOLLARS TO PROVIDE ITS
TUITION ASSISTANCE- TO PURSUE A
MASTERS IN SOCIAL WORK- AND
AGAIN TO HELP BRING- INDIVIDUAL
INTERPRETATION PROFESSION THAT
WORK IN PLACEMENT SERVICES FOR
FOSTER YOUTH. AND SO WE'RE VERY
PLEASED TO SPONSOR THIS MEASURE-
AND- LOOK FORWARD TO YOUR
SUPPORT TODAY THANK YOU THANK
YOU SO MUCH ATTENTION IS VERY
GRATEFUL FOR THAT WE'RE NOT
GOING TO BE TURNING OVER TO
COMMITTEE BOTH THOSE WHO ARE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY AS WELL
AS HERE WE'RE GONNA START WITH.
SENATOR LEYVA AND LOOKS LIKE WE
ALSO HAVE CENTER PAN WHO'D LIKE
TO SAY A FEW WORDS AS WELL
CENTER LEYVA. PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK YOU SENATOR. I HAVE NO
COMMENTS THANK CENTER OFFERING
THE BILL FORWARD. THANK YOU SO
MUCH CENTER LATER THIS GO TO
SENATOR PAN I THANK YOU VERY
MUCH CENTER OUT THE REALLY
APPRECIATE BRING THIS BILL
FORWARD- AND- ALSO APPRECIATE
YOUR COMMENTS ABOUT- ADDRESSING
SOME OF THE ISSUES ARE REYES AND
ANALYSIS JUST ONE OTHER
QUESTION. I KNOW THIS BILLS
SEEKING TO BUILD ON THE TITLES
FOR EASY FINDING DO YOU HAVE A
SENSE OF THE TERM BECAUSE THIS
TUITION ASSISTANCE- HOW MUCH
TUITION ASSISTANCE BUSINESS.
BUILDING REQUIRE BOTH CAL STATE
MATCHING MONEY FOR THE FOR E. R.
I'M JUST TRYING TO CLARIFY
EXACTLY HOW MUCH TUITION
ASSISTANCE AND HE WAS A GREAT
IDEA. BUT THAT HAVE YET TO
ANSWER THAT I DON'T TO CENTER I
DO NOT HAVE A FIGURE FOR YOU IN
TERMS OF THE DOLLAR AMOUNT OF
TUITION ASSISTANCE. THIS
CERTAINLY TRACKS WITH THE
EXISTING MODEL FOR YOU PROGRAMS
WITH RESPECT TO OF A LOT OF
SOCIAL WORKERS- IN THAT SENSE
AND OF COURSE PROBATION OFFICERS
PERFORM THIS SAME SERVICE AND
SO. THE KEY IS TO SORT OF ATTACK
THE PROBATION OFFICERS ON TO THE
EXISTING PROGRAM AND TO VOTE FOR
THEM THE SAME OPPORTUNITIES FOR
ADVANCED EDUCATION AGAINST HIM
OR IN A NARROW THE FIELD SORT OF
FEELS- SO THEY CAN PROVIDE
APPROPRIATE SERVICES TO FOSTER
KIDS I'M A POP CULTURE AS WELL
TRY TO GET THAT INFORMATION. TO
YOU BETWEEN NOW SHOULD THE BILL
PASS OUT AND THE TIME YOU SEE IT
AGAIN ON THE FLOOR OKAY
APPRECIATE JUST- BE HELPFUL TO
KNOW WHAT THE EXACTLY THE SCOPE
OF THE SYSTEMS WITH A BILL
PROVIDE BUT WITH THAT AGAIN
REALLY APPRECIATE HAVING THIS
BILL FORD OBVIOUSLY SOMETHING
NEEDED- BY OUR PROBATION
DEPARTMENTS AND I'M HAPPY TO
MOVE THE BILL AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU SO MUCH CENTER PAIN
WITH THE MOTION ON THE FLOOR
MOTION ONTHE FLOOR BY CENTER
PAN WE'RE GONNA CONTINUE WITH
OUR CONVERSATION- WE'RE GOING TO
TURN IT OVER TO OUR VICE CHAIR.
ABOUT. YOUR CHILDREN PLEASE
PROCEED. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
GREAT BATTLE AND- OF THE- YOU
BUT WE'RE- THANK YOU SO MUCH I
THEN BY THE- WITH ACTIVITIES IF
THERE'S ANY. QUESTIONS IS GONNA
LAST CALL QUESTIONS FROM CAN. NO
ONE'S PHYSICAL AND- OR A-
VIRTUAL HAND UP. HI SO. ANSWER
CENTER. YOUR GERMAN- CENTER.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSELY. THANK
YOU- MISTER. COLLEAGUES THAT PER
. YOUR SUPPORT AGAIN. IS FEDERAL
MONEY. UNDER TITLE FORTY.
VALUABLE PROGRAM. FIGHTING
AGITATION SERVICES TWO VALUABLE
PARTICIPANTS IN THIS FOSTER CARE
PROGRAM RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE AND I WILL AGAIN THANK
MY- FELLOW AUTHORS IN THE ROOM
AND OTHER WAS HERE FOR THEIR
PATIENTS THANK YOU SIR THANK YOU
SO MUCH INTO RUSSIA I UNDERSTAND
THAT YOU ARE UNDER SOME TIME
CONSTRAINTS TODAY SO WE'RE
REALLY GRATEFUL THAT YOU'RE ABLE
TO BE FLEXIBLE AS WELL SO THANK
YOU. THE MOTION ON THE FLOOR BY
CENTER PAN THE MOTION IS TO PASS
BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS OUR
CHIEF CONSULTANT IS NOW GOING TO
READ THE MOTION ONCE AGAIN IN
CALL THE ROLL MISSLER. FILE ITEM
NUMBER FIVE SB SIX TWENTY TO THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR LEYVA.
CENTER LEYVA SB SIX TWO TWO BY
LEYVA HI OCHO A BOGUS. SO CHORE
OVER. AND SIXTY YEAR I. JOE BOGA
OCCUR. BY PARTISI I'D DELHI.
SENATOR DOLLY SB SIX TWO TWO HI
KELLY I GLAZER GLAZER AYE
MCGUIRE MCGUIRE AYE PAN. FIVE
NINE SEVEN ZERO. GENERALLY A
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AT THE SEVEN
ZERO VOTE THE BILL IS OUT OR
CLOSE THE ROLE THANK YOU SO MUCH
MEMBERS THINKS IN IRAQ THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU SO MUCH ALL
RIGHT CENTER PORTANTINO IT'S
BEEN INCREDIBLY PATIENT THANK
YOU SO MUCH CENTER PORTANTINO WE
APOLOGIZE ABOUT KEEPING YOU
WAITING THANK YOU FOR YOUR
FLEXIBILITY WITH OUR COLLEAGUE
THERE. THAT CENTER PORTANTINO-
IS GONNA BE PRESENTING ON SENATE
BILL THREE EIGHTY SEVEN THAT'S A
PORTANTINO IS GOING TO
PARTICIPATE REMOTELY IS MARTINO
WELCOME THE FLOOR IS YOURS YOUR
NOW LIFE. THANK U. S. SENATE
REQUIRE AND SENATOR LEYVA OR
CHAIR LEYVA OR- THE OPPORTUNITY
PRESENTS SB THREE EIGHTY SEVEN
AND DOCTOR PANDITS WHO IS
WILLING 2% IN ANY EVENT THAT I
COULD NOT CORRECT. PRESENT
REMOTELY SO THANK YOU ALL FOR
YOUR COOPERATION- I'D LIKE TO
START OBVIOUSLY BY THANKING THE
COMMITTEE STAFF. AND THE CHAIR-
SO OFFICE FOR WORKING DILIGENTLY
WITH MY STAFF AND THE SPONSORS
OF THIS BILL. TO GET IT IN THE
PLACE WHERE IT IS TODAY-
CALIFORNIA IS IN THE MIDST OF A
YOU YOUTH BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
CRISIS. EXACERBATED BY THE COLD
WITH NINETEEN PANDEMIC NOTHING
WE ALLDON'T. SEE IN OUR
DISTRICT SAID AROUND OUR
FAMILIES AND AROUND A
CALIFORNIA. WITH DISTANCE
LEARNING OUR YOUTH ARE
INCREASINGLY ISOLATED AND
DISENGAGED WITH DEPRESSION
SYMPTOMS. AT ALL TIME HIGH FOR
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS. ACCORDING
TO THE U. S. DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES NEARLY
ONE IN THREE CALIFORNIA HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS. SURVEYED
REPORTED FEELING SAD OR HOPELESS
ALMOST EVERY DAY FOR TWO OR MORE
WEEKS IN A ROW. NEARLY ONE IN
FIVE REPORTED THAT THEY HAVE
SERIOUSLY CONSIDERED ATTEMPTING
SUICIDE. I DON'T WANT TO READ
ANOTHER CHILD TAKING THEIR OWN
LIFE- IN CALIFORNIA I JUST DON'T
WANT TO READ ABOUT IT SH I DON'T
WANT TO SEE IT AND I THINK WE
NEED TO DO EVERYTHING WE CAN TO
PREVENT TO TEACH. TEACHERS AND
SCHOOL STAFF ARE ON THE FRONT
LINES OF THESE CRISES. AS OUR
STAFF HAS SUCH MUST BE TRAINED
TO IDENTIFY AND HELP STUDENTS
WHO ARE SUFFERING- IF YOU
REMEMBER. LAST YEAR WHEN WE
PRESENTED THIS BILL THE FATHER
WHO CALLED IN AND TALKED ABOUT A
FOURTEEN YEAR OLD DAUGHTER. WHO
TURNED IN HER- JOURNALIST SIMON
IN SCHOOL. I'VE GOT AN A ON THE
ASSIGNMENT AND THEN SHORTLY
THEREAFTER TOOK HER OWN LIFE.
AND THE FATHER WAS CHAU. BUT
POIGNANT IN THAT HE SAID I DON'T
PLAY THE TEACHER FOR NOT SEEING
THIS. OF SUICIDE IN DAUGHTER
JOURNAL BE THE TEACHER WASN'T.
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
MAKING SURE THAT PEOPLE ARE
TRAINED AND RESEARCH SHOWS. THAT
THE SOONER PEOPLE GET HELP FOR
MENTAL HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE USE
CONCERNS THE MORE LIKELY THEY
ARE TO HAVE POSITIVE OUTCOMES.
THIS BILL IS MORE IMPORTANT THAN
EVER BECAUSE THE SCHOOLS ARE
TRANSITIONING. CAN PERSON
LEARNING AND FRANKLY YOU KNOW
MANY OF THEM. HAVE GONE TO A
HYBRID APPROACH RECENTLY
TEACHERS ARE ENCOUNTERING
BEHAVIOR HEALTH ISSUES RESULTING
FROM EMOTIONAL IMPACTS OF THE
PANDEMIC ON THEIR STUDENTS. THE
REALITY IS THAT WHEN STUDENTS
RETURN TO SCHOOL THEIR TRAUMA
AND DEPRESSION RETURN WITH THEM.
IF WE DON'T TRAIN TEACHERS THEY
WILL BE LEFT OUT. WITHOUT THE
TOOLS THEY NEED TO HELP IDENTIFY
CRISIS WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE
STAFF. ADMINISTRATORS EVERYONE
THAT COMES IN CONTACT WITH THEIR
KIDS. HAS THIS TRAINING- IT. A
LACK OF TRAINING DOESN'T KEEP
THE STUDENTS DEPRESSION OR
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER AT HOME-
WELL LIKE EXISTING LAW CALLS
FROM THE CUE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
IDENTIFIED EVIDENCE BASED MENTAL
HEALTH TRAINING PROGRAM. IT DOES
NOT REQUIRE SCHOOLS TO ESTABLISH
THE TRAINING PROGRAM FOR THEIR
STUDENTS STAFF AND TEACHERS. SB
THREE EIGHTY SEVEN HELPS ADDRESS
THIS PROBLEM BY REQUIRING THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF.
EDUCATION TO ENSURE THAT 75% OF
ALL ITS CLASSIFIED AND CERTIFIED
EMPLOYEES ON SCHOOL CAMPUSES.
COMPETE COMPLETE AN EVIDENCE
BASED BEHAVIORAL TRAINING
PROGRAM. MANDATING OF THE
EVIDENCE BASED PROGRAM FOR I
WILL PROVIDE ESSENTIAL
INSTRUCTIONS. ON HOW STUDENTS
TEACHERS AND STAFF CAN BEST
PROVIDE REFERRALS TO MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER SERVICES OR OTHER
SUPPORT INDIVIDUAL. INDIVIDUALS
IN CRISIS I WANT TO BE CLEAR.
THIS TRAINING DOES NOT ATTEMPT
TO TURN STAFF AND TEACHERS. INTO
MENTAL HEALTH PROFESSIONALS.
THIS MANDATED TRAINING SIMPLY
TEACHES AN INDIVIDUAL HOW. TO
SPOT WHEN THERE IS A PROBLEM.
WITH THIS OR- IN FACT I SEE THIS
JUSTICE THE CENTER C. OR FIRST
AID TAKE A FIRST AID COURSE
DOESN'T MAKE YOU A MEDICAL
PROFESSIONAL TAKING A FIRST AID
COURSE TRAINS YOU. ON HOW TO GET
HELP WHEN YOU SEE A CRISIS AND
THIS IS WHY WE MUST ALSO SHOW
THAT WE VALUE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
NEEDS OF STUDENTS. JUST LIKE WE
VALUE PHYSICAL HEALTH NEEDS
WE'RE STILL IN A PANDEMIC AND WE
CANNOT AFFORD TO IGNORE THIS
ISSUE STUDENTS ARE PRESENTED
WITH. KIDS NEED OUR HELP TO BE
SAFE AT SCHOOL AND THEY SHOULD
BE BANNED THERE SHOULD INCLUDE
MENTAL HEALTH TRAINING THIS BILL
IS SPONSORED BY A BROAD
COALITION OF BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS AND MENTAL HEALTH
ADVOCATES INCLUDING THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL COMMUNITY
HEALTH AGENCIES. THE CALIFORNIA
STUDENT WORK ARE STUDENT BOARD
MEMBERS ASSOCIATION DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA GENERATION UP
AN INSEPARABLE ON THE PHONE WITH
ME TODAY I HAVE TO WORK YOUR
WORK BACK TEACHER SPECIALIST AT
COLLEGE VIEW SCHOOL. AND ZACHARY
PATTERSON PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA STUDENT BOARD MEMBER
ASSOCIATION TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL AND RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE WHEN
APPROPRIATE. THANK YOU SO MUCH
CENTER THIS IS BEING VERY
PERSONAL FOR YOU AND P. SHE USED
CAMPINAS AND A CRITICAL ISSUE
WE'RE NOT GOING TO BE GOING TO
MISTER O'ROURKE. HARDWORKING
TEACHER HE'S GOING TO BE OUR
FIRST WITNESS TODAY MISTER
ROURKE YOU HAVE. TO MEET MICKEY
. HI PAUL. HIGH IS SAID MR I
INSIST. MR ROURKE- DO APOLOGIZE
ABOUT THAT AND WORK WE WELCOME I
. COMMITTEE U. S. TO TOO MANY
AND I'LL GIVE YOU A THREE.
SECOND PROMPT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
CORKY ARE WORK AND I'VE BEEN A
TEACHER OF GENERAL EDUCATION AND
SPECIAL EDUCATION FOR THIRTY
EIGHT YEARS. I HAVE TAUGHT IN
DENVER BOSTON AND NOW L. A.
COUNTY FOR MY ENTIRE CAREER AND
I HAVE NEVER BEEN MANDATED TO
CREATE IN MENTAL HEALTH
AWARENESS. I MADE A CALIFORNIA
TO TEACH IN NINETEEN NINETY ONE
I GOT CAUGHT. SUFFERING FROM
DEPRESSION ANXIETY OF. THE HOME
EXCESSIVE AGGRESSION. WITH VITAL
IDEATION IT'S A GREAT IDEA AND
SELF HARM. AND LET ME REITERATE
I HAVE NEVER BEEN GIVEN THE
TRAINING TO EFFECTIVELY AND
APPROPRIATELY DEAL WITH THE
SEVERE MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES. I
HAVE VOLUNTARILY SOUGHT OUT THE
TRAINING BUT TO LEAD TO THIS
KIND OF CRITICAL TRAINING THE
VOLUNTARY PARTICIPATION IT'S
LIKE PREACHING TO THE CHOIR.
IT'S THE MAJORITY OF TEACHERS
SUPPORT STAFF AND RESOURCE
PROVIDERS THAT MARK. HAVE
TRAINING. BILL IS ASKING 45% THE
AND CLASSIFIED PERSONNEL TO BE
TRAINED IN MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES
AND I ASKED WHY NOT A HUNDRED
PERCENT. ALL SCHOOL PERSONNEL
SHOULD BE ABLE TO IDENTIFY IF
SUPPORTERS. WITH MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES THIS MAY BE AS SIMPLE AS
NOTICING THE SAME. COMING HOME
LATE EVERY MORNING HERE ON
WATCHED WEARING THE SAME
CLOTHING EVERY DAY I KNOW NOT
BUT ONCE DOING ONE AND SHE MAY
NOT OPEN UP TO ME BUT I COULD
BRING COULD BLOW THAT SOMETHING
IS AMISS. AND I COULD CONTACT
THE ADULT BUT SHE- OKAY TO BEGIN
THE CAR SEE IF SHE TO CALL IN
SOME WAY. IT'S KIND OF A WAY IS
ABSOLUTELY BY. TO IN ALL THREE
THAT ARE WITH OF ONLY.
LONELINESS AND KNOWING WHERE TO
TURN THIRTY SECONDS IN EIGHT
POWER FOR HEIGHTS- CHRONICALLY
FATTER HOPEFULLY. I HAVE A CLASS
OF THIRTY. BUT. IT FROM THE
MEDIA OUR SOCCER IN SOME. MORE
THAN FIFTY PER OF LTP Q.
STUDENTS. FILE I. THAT MORE THAN
EVER EVER BASED TRAINING. THE
APPS MANDATE ALL HE DID IN CLASS
PER. ALSO 75% BUT WE SHOULD ALL
KNOW HOW TO. AND FELT ARE HEALTH
DRUG. THANK YOU CAN OPPORTUNITY
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR ME OVER
WERE GREATER FOR YOUR TEST TODAY
IT'S TO HEAR- IN REALLY P. YOUR
AB. RIGHT NOW I'M BE GOING TO
CHECK REPAIR SIN HE'S A COW
STUDENT MAY- HE FROM THE
COMPANIES TO BOARD MEMBER S. OF
. TO PATTERSON WE WILL YOU TO
COME YOU HAVE MANY WE'LL GIVE
YOU A SECOND PRO YOUR NOW LAW
PLEASE PROCEED. THE MORNING
CHAIRWOMAN THEY'VE FELON. MY
NAME IS PATTERSON AT I SERVE AS
A MEMBER OF THE SAN DIEGO BORDER
THAT. THE PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA STUDENT BOARD MEMBER
ASSOCIATION BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY
AS A STUDENT. A STUDENT WHO
FEELS A STUDENT WHO STRUGGLES.
TO STUDENT WHO KNOWS THAT MY
MENTAL HEALTH AND WELL BEING. IS
JUST AS IMPORTANT AS BREAKING A
BONE OR FEELING SACK. WHEN I
THINK ABOUT WHY SPEAK TO ALL OF
YOU TODAY. I THINK IT'S FOR
STUDENT AT MY SCHOOL A FRIEND OF
MINE. JOHN JOHN WITH MY
CLASSMATES FELLOW TRACK RUNNER
AND SO MUCH MORE. I TRULY
APPRECIATED JOHN FOR WHAT HE WAS
A BRAVE BOY WHO BRIGHTENED
EVERYONE'S DAY. DESPITE THIS
THERE WAS ALWAYS SOMETHING
UNDERLYING THE INCESSANT JOKES
ABOUT SUICIDE. THE FREQUENT
SUDDENNESS THAT WOULD OVERCOME
THEM. I DIDN'T KNOW HOW TO
RESPOND. I DIDN'T KNOW WHAT TO
DO. I DID WHAT MOST KIDS DO. NOT
MUCH ANY OF TWENTY TWO. MY JOHN
TOOK HIS OWN LIFE. WE WERE
SHOCKED AT THE SAME TIME THERE
WERE SIGNS. SIGNS THAT COULD
HAVE AND SHOULD HAVE BEEN
RECOGNIZED. I KNOW I COULD HAVE
DONE TO SUPPORT I KNOW I COULD
HAVE DONE BETTER TO SUPPORT JOHN
INSIDE STAFF HAD BEEN GIVEN THAT
KNOWLEDGE AND EDUCATION. IF
TEACHERS HAD BEEN ABLE TO
RECOGNIZE THE SIGNS. AND NOW I'M
HERE BECAUSE SB TREAT SEVEN IS
MY CHANCE. IT'S OUR CHANCE. TO
PROVIDE THE RESOURCES AND
TRAINING ON HOW TO HANDLE MENTAL
HEALTH CRISES. BUT ALSO TO HELP
EACH OTHER AS TEACHERS BECAUSE
TEACHERS FACE THEIR OWN MENTAL
HEALTH CONCERNS TO. SPEAKING
ABOUT MENTAL HEALTH AND REMOVING
THE STIGMA AT SCHOOL IS THE ONLY
WAY THAT WE ARE GOING TO BE
SUCCESSFUL. IN TURNING THE TIDE
IN SUPPORT OF HEALTH AND
WELLBEING THIRTY SECONDS
DISTRICTS ACROSS THE STATE HAVE
MADE STRIDES. IN SUPPORTING
PROGRAMS THAT ADVOCATE FOR
MENTAL HEALTH. AS A SCHOOL BOARD
MEMBER I CAN PERSONALLY ATTEST
TO OUR EXCITEMENT THE NEW
RESOURCES. THAT ARE FINALLY
DEDICATED. BUT IT'S TIME TO GO A
STEP FURTHER AND PREPARE OUR
TEACHERS AND STAFF. BECAUSE WE
THE STUDENTS WE'RE WORTH THE
TRAINING. ON BEHALF OF STUDENTS
FROMACROSS CALIFORNIA AS
REPRESENTATIVE THE CALIFORNIA
STUDENT BOARD MEMBERS OF THE
ASIAN. I URGE THE SENATE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE TO SHOW THE
MENTAL HEALTH MATTERS AND NOT IN
SUPPORT OF SB THREE EIGHT SEVEN.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH AS
PASSING GRADE COMPUTER TESTIMONY
TODAY LADIES AND GENTLEMEN OF
COMMITTEE WERE NOT GOING TO SEE
IF THERE'S ANYONE IN SUPPORT OF
SB THREE EIGHT SEVEN IN ROOM
FORTY TWO- THREE. ARE CAN YOU
PLEASE STAND. SEEN KNOWN STAND
WE'RE NOT GOING TO GO TO OUR
LIVE TELECONFERENCE NINE. WE'RE
GOING TO ASK THE MODERATOR TO
PLEASE QUEUE UP ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHO WOULD LIKE TO BE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB. THREE EIGHTY
SEVEN NOW. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR IF YOU'D LIKE TO SEE AND
SO. OF THIS LEGISLATION PLEASE
PRAY TIME.
START WITH MY NUMBER FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MARICA
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE HARSH
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES IN LA AND
ORANGE COUNTIES GOING TO CONVEY
OUR STRONG SUPPORT FOR SENATE
BILL THREE EIGHTY SEVEN THANK
YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
PHONE CALL THIS MORNING THIS GO
TO OUR NEXT CALLER. PINE THIRTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD
MORNING THIS IS WENDY **** WHAT
SECOND MARK H. COMMUNITY MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES PROVIDER
HEADQUARTERED IN THE TWENTY
FIFTH SENATE DISTRICT AND WE
AREN'T STRONG SUPPORT OF SB
THREE EIGHTY SEVEN THANKS TWENTY
LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NEXT TO THE LINE THIRTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. ROBLIN
WITH THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF
COMMUNITY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
AGENCIES PROUD SPONSOR AND
SUPPORT THANKS SO MUCH ROB LET'S
GO TO OUR NEXT LINE PLEASE. NEXT
HEADLINE TWENTY TO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO GOOD MORNING THE
THIRD LEVEL COURSE OF CLARK AND
THE STUDENTS FROM BERKELEY
CALIFORNIA- AND A REPRESENTATIVE
FROM GENERATION UP THE STUDENT
LED YOUTH ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION
AND WE'RE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PHONE CALL TODAY NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. EXCEPT ONE FORTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD MORNING
DANIELLE GAVE ME WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE THE CHILD
AND FAMILY SERVICES AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU DANIELLE NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. ONE FIFTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND
MEMBERS COLLINS FOR US WITH THE
CALIFORNIA PSYCHOLOGICAL
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT WE
SHOULD THE PHONE CALL COLIN WE
GO TO OUR NEXT LINE PLEASE. ONE
FIFTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF
THE WHITE. HOUSE ME ON BEHALF OF
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA AND
WE ARE APART THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR PHONE CALL LET'S COVER
AN EXCELLENT. ONE FORTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I MEAN I'M
DOCTOR CHRISTINE PETTIT BASED
PRESIDENT OF PUBLIC POLICY AND
ADVOCACY FOR MENTAL HEALTH
AMERICA OF LOS ANGELES I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF MY
ORGANIZATION IN SUPPORT OF SB
THREE EIGHTY FIVE AND THANK YOU
FOR CONSIDERING THIS LIFESAVING
LEGISLATION. THANK YOU SO MUCH
DOCTOR NEXT CALLER PLEASE. PINE
THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BUY MOVIE THE CALIFORNIA ACCESS
. INCLUDE PORT. A DIFFICULT
TODAY NEXT LINE PLEASE. LINE
FORTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE GUY
DIDN'T GET THE COUNTY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU SO MUCH THAT'S
CURRENT EXCELLENT. MISTER CHAIR
WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THE WORKERS TO MODERATOR WE'RE
NOT GOING TO BE CHECKING IN TO
SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE OPPOSED TO
SP THREE EIGHTY SEVEN. WE'RE
GONNA START IN ROOM FORTY TWO-
THREE SINCE WE DO NOT HAVE ANY
LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESSES ON
RECORD TODAY I SEE NO ONE RISE
IN ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE WE'RE
GONNA GO RIGHT BACK TO YOU
GUESSED IT TO THE TELECONFERENCE
WIND WE'RE GONNA CHECK IN WITH
THE MODERATOR MR MODERATOR IF
YOU WANT TO QUEUE UP. ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION TO SB THREE EIGHTY
SEVEN NOW. THANK YOU MISTER FEEL
LIKE SPEAKING OPPOSITION OF THIS
LEGISLATION PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN. ZERO WE DO HAVE LINE
THIRTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOU CARE
MEMBERS. AFTER PORTANTINO THIS
IS TONY TO GUERO ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION. I HAVE REACHED OUT
TO THE SENATOR STAFF ABOUT TWO
SB THREE EIGHTY SEVEN AND
IDENTIFIED A FEW AREAS OF
CONCERN GIVEN THE SHORT TIME
LINE BETWEEN THE RETURN OF THE
LEGISLATURE IN TODAY'S HEARING.
OUR CPA ORGANIZATION WILL BE
REVIEWING THE MEASURE AT OUR
VIRTUAL STATE COUNCIL MEETING.
THIS WEEKEND AS REPRESENT IN THE
ANALYSIS ON PAGE THREE NUMBER
TWO UNDERSTAFFED COMMENT. CTA
HAD IN OPPOSE POSITION ON THE
VERSION REFERENCE AS WELL AS THE
SPECIFIC USE AB ALL HEALTH
SYMPTOMS. THAT HAVE BEEN RE
INSERTED IN SB THREE EIGHTY
SEVEN. WE DO LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE SENATOR AND THE
BILL'S SPONSORS. GOING FORWARD
THANK YOU. THANK SO MUCH YOUR
PHONE TODAY WERE TO TAKE THAT AS
OUR- LEAD. WE WILL SAY OPPOSITE
BUT LEAD- WOULDN'T WITH SOME
CONCERN SO KNOW THAT CENTER
PORTANTINO WILL BE ENGAGING ON
THAT IS WELL THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR PHONE CALL TODAY. LET'S
CHECK IN WITH THE MODERATOR TO
SEE IF WE HAVE ANYONE ELSE
EITHER WITH CONCERNS OR IN
OPPOSITION SB THREE EIGHTY SEVEN
. SURE WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE
QUEUED UP AT THIS TIME THANK YOU
SO MUCH. RIGHT PLACE GERMAN
WE'RE GONNA BRING IT BACK OVER
TO THAT COMMITTEE WE'RE GOING TO
GO TO CENTER LABOR FIRST EVER TO
GO TO CENTER CORTESE. CENTER
GLAZER CENTER PAN AND THEN OF
COURSE WE'LL CHECK IN REMOTELY
AS WELL CENTER LEYVA IF YOU
WANNA KICK US OFF PLEASE. VERY
MUCH SENATE MCGUIRE. MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE I JUST WANT TO
REMIND US THAT WE DID PASSED A
VERSION OF THIS BILL OUT OF THIS
COMMITTEE LAST YEAR. SB
FOURTEEN- IT DID GET AMENDED IN
THE U. S. AND THE ASSEMBLY. AND
THE SEVEN NINETY FIVE. PERCENT
WENT DOWN TO FIFTY PERCENT- SO
I'M STEP RECOMMENDED WE SUPPORT
THE BILL AGAIN. BUT JUST
REMINDING FOLKS THAT THAT BILL
DID GO INTO LAW LAST YEAR SB
FOURTEEN. SO THIS- AS AN ATTEMPT
TO BRING IT BACK 275% SO HE SAID
WE WILL DO WHAT THE ASSEMBLY
DOES- BUT WE HAVE ALREADY PASSED
THIS BILL SO I WOULD RECOMMEND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU SO MUCH
CENTER LATER LET'S GO TO CENTER
CORTESE. THANK YOU FOR OF IN.
LET ME JUST ASK QUESTIONS- TO
SENATOR PORTANTINO FIRST OF ALL
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD AGAIN I WAS SUPPORT LAST
YEAR. APPRECIATE THE I
APPRECIATE THE EXCELLENT WORK
YOU'RE DOING IN THIS AREA- THE
ONE QUESTION I HAVE. WHICH IS
MORE CURIOSITY AT THIS POINT IS-
WITH THE JANUARY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE- CERTIFICATION DATE-
FOR THIS NEW STANDARD A
REQUIREMENT IS IT. IS IT ASSUMED
I'M REALLY JUST LOOKING FOR YOUR
INTENT OR YOUR THOUGHT ON THIS.
THAT THAT THE COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING PROCESS WILL. DO WHAT
IT NEEDS TO DO DURING THAT TIME
DISTRICT BY DISTRICT COMMITTEE
PRICKLY INSERVICE STATES IN
TRAINING DATES AND- WHAT THEY'RE
FOR- HOW THE B. USER ARE ALL
THINGS THAT AT LEAST IN THE
UNIONIZED CIRCUMSTANCES THAT ARE
THAT ARE BARGAINED FOR- I'M
ASSUMING THAT. THIS BILL DOESN'T
GET IN THE WAY OF THAT HAPPENING
AND- I HAVE NO IDEA WHETHER OR
NOT IT CAN HAPPEN BETWEEN NOW
AND TWENTY TWENTY FIVE- BUT
AGAIN I. AM SUPPORTIVE EITHER
WAY I'M JUST CURIOUS AS TO WHAT
YOUR THOUGHTS ON THAT SENATOR.
YEAH I DON'T IT ENTERED WITH THE
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING- PROCESS I
MEAN WORK WORK WORK MANDATING
TRAINING. FOR ALL 475% OF SCHOOL
PERSONNEL- AND YOU KNOW WE'RE WE
HAVE AN AGGRESSIVE TIMELINE
BECAUSE FRANKLY THE NEED. IS
AGGRESSIVE YOU KNOW THAT IMPACT
OUR KIDS IS AGGRESSIVE- THE TOLL
ON MENTAL HEALTH IS AGGRESSIVE
AND I THINK WE NEED TO BE
AGGRESSIVE AND YOU KNOW AS THE
CHAIR POINTED OUT- INEXPLICABLY-
THE ASSEMBLY EDUCATION
COMMITTEE- FORCED THE REMOVAL OF
THE SECTION LAST YEAR- AND- YOU
KNOW IT'S A SHAME THAT THAT
HAPPENED BECAUSE THAT'S WHEN
YOU'RE LOST. AND GOD KNOWS HOW
MANY LIVES WILL BE LOST BECAUSE
OF THAT ONE YEAR DELAY- AND YOU
KNOW WHAT IF THEY DO IT AGAIN
THIS YEAR I'M GONNA BRING IT
BACK NEXT YEAR AND IF THEY DO IT
AGAIN NEXT YEAR TO BRING IT BACK
AGAIN NEXT YEAR. I'M NOT GONNA
STOP UNTIL 75% OR GOOD HEALTHY
PORTION OF OUR SCHOOL PERSONNEL
ARE TRAINED TO HELP OUR KIDS-
AND YOU KNOW MY PLEASE IF ANY OF
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS ARE
LISTENING IS. YOU KNOW WHEN I'M
NOT GOING AWAY THIS ISSUE ISN'T
GOING AWAY AND WILL WORK OUT
WHATEVER WE NEED TO WORK OUT
WITH THE IMPLEMENTATION OF IT-
TO MAKE IT A STRONG AND IT'S
BURDEN AS POSSIBLE BUT EVERY DAY
WE DON'T HELP OUR KIDS. WE RUN
THE RISK OF LOSING A KID AND-
I'M JUST NOT GONNA LET THAT
HAPPEN- THROUGH THE SURE THING
YOU I. AND I. RESPONSIBLE
QUESTION THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP. AB SO MUCH THIS
INTERPRETATIVE GOING TO SEND
GLAZER MORNING. THANK THANK YOU
. AND YOU KNOW WE ALL HAVE-
DIFFERENT EXPERIENCES IN OUR
LIFE WITH SUICIDE- I THINK IT
WOULD BE UNUSUAL IF SOMEONE NOT.
AS FOR ME- A FELLOW CLASSMATE IN
COLLEGE TOOK HIS OWN LIFE. I'VE
HAD A RELATIVE TO TAKE HIS OWN
LIFE. JUST A FEW WEEKS AGO. A
MEMBER OF OUR COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS. RECENTLY MARRIED
HEADER HUSBAND TAKE HIS OWN LIFE
IS- SHE'S HAD THE COURAGE TO
TALK ABOUT IT- AND IT WHEN THESE
THINGS HAPPENED WHAT DO WE THINK
ABOUT WHAT TO WE FEEL. WE CRY
AND WE CRY AND WE CRY. AND WE
SAY WHAT COULD WE HAVE DONE.
WHAT COULD WE HAVE KNOWN. AND IT
IS WHY I AM SO PLEASED TO SEE
THE LEADERSHIP OF MY COLLEAGUE
SENATOR PORTANTINO AND SO MANY
OTHERS- WHO RECOGNIZE THAT THESE
ARE THINGS WE HAVE TO TALK ABOUT
AND MORE THAN TALK ABOUT AMONG
OURSELVES BUT TO CREATE A
CLIMATE IN WHICH WE CAN TALK
ABOUT IT AS A COMMUNITY. AND TO
MAKE SURE WE ARE TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT THE STEPS WE CAN TAKE
TO MAKE IT BETTER. AND I
APPRECIATE SENATOR PORTANTINO
YOUR- LEADERSHIP IN THIS SPACE I
APPRECIATE YOUR TO NATION'S
NESS- AND NOT GIVING UP- IN
FINDING CONSTRUCTIVE WAYS. THAT
WE CAN DO BETTER AND HELP EACH
OTHER BETTER. AND WITH THAT I'M
PLEASED TO SUPPORT THE BILL AND
WITH ABILITY FOR FREE TIME.
THANK YOU FOR THAT INDIA FOR
THOSE PERSONAL WORDS IS WELL
WE'RE VERY GRATEFUL CENTER
GLAZERS WHO HAVE A MOTION ON THE
FLOOR. SB THREE EIGHTY SEVEN IF
IT'S ALRIGHT WITH MISTER PAIN I
DECIDED TO GO TO THE VICE CHAIR
QUICKLY AND THEN IF THAT'S
ALRIGHT WITH YOU. MADAM VICE
CHAIR- WANT TO TURN IT OVER TO
YOU KNOW WHERE TO GO TO CENTER
CAMDEN CENTER DOLLY BETTER BY
SURE THE FLOOR IS YOURS PLEASE.
IN HERE. I MAJOR EFFORTS ON THE
STATE AND- IT ALSO FOR OF THIS
GIRL TODAY. I DO HAVE A CONCERN
TO OR LOCAL SCHOOLWORK IN GIVING
. NINETY FOR STAMP ON THE NAY TO
OUR SOURCE WILL DISTRICTS YOU
IMPLEMENT AN I WAS CURIOUS AND
FRONT ARE THERE ANY CONSIDER ANY
DISCUSS ON WHETHER OR NOT THEY
WOULD BE. GRANTED A LOCAL WORSE
DISTRICTS YOU ABLE TO THIS- YES-
IS TRAINING. CENTERPOINT AT WITH
THE CHAIRS PLEASE. NO MY IS TO
HAVE IT FOR WITHIN THE BY AS
WELL- BUT I RECOGNIZE THERE'S
GOING TO BE DISH- FINING CROSS-
AT I- AM HOPEFUL THAT THE BILL
GETTING THROUGH THIS IS LAYS
FOUNDATION FOR BY OUT. FOR
MEDIVATION ANY UP ON THE PLEASE
. THANK YOU VERY MUCH WORDS.
THANK MA'AM BYE CHAIR AT ITS
CHRISTIAN PAN THE CENTER ON THE
CENTER MORE THANK YOU I WANT TO
SAN FOURTEEN FOR HIS LEADERS AND
ISSUE. HE WAS A PARTNER WITH ME
BACK IN TWENTY NINETEEN WHEN I
AUTHORED A BILL WHICH
UNFORTUNATELY GOT THE VETOED BY
THE GOVERNOR BUT I APPRECIATE
THAT HE'S TAKEN UP THE MANTLE
AND- HS MOVED FORWARD BOTH HIS
PREVIOUS LEGISLATION WHICH IS
NOW LAW BUT THEN ALSO AGAIN
COMING BACK TO US TODAY TO SAY
THAT WE NEED. MORE TEACHERS WHO
ARE TRAINED- TO IDENTIFY MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES AND THAT AND I
ALSO WANT JUST EMPHASIZING I
REALLY APPRECIATE CENTER
PORTANTINO BRING UP THIS WE'RE
NOT EXPECTING SCHOOL STAFF AND
TEACHERS. TO BECOME MENTAL
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS- IN FACT WE
NEED TO WORK TO BE SURE THAT WE
FUND THE MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS UNNECESSARY
PROVIDE THE CARE FOR. THE
STUDENTS THE CHILDREN. WHO ARE
NOTIFIED BY THE TEACHERS. AND IN
FACT I THINK IN THE LAST BUDGET
WE BUDGETED UP FOUR BILLION
DOLLARS FOR YOUTH MENTAL HEALTH-
WOULD BE PERHAPS WE'LL SEE
WHETHER WE MIGHT NEED TO DO
MORE. BUT WE OF COURSE NEED TO
BUILD UP THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
WORKFORCE AS WELL. BUT HIS
CENTER PORTANTINO SAID WE ALSO
NEED TO BE SURE OF THAT- THE
PEOPLE ON THE FRONT LINES AND
THAT'S WHERE TEACHERS ARE THERE
ON THE FRONT LINES AND I KNOW
THEY'RE VERY BUSY HAND THEY'RE
STRESSED. AND PERHAPS EVEN CELLS
COULD USE A MENTAL SUPPORT TO
BECAUSE OF THE STRESS THAT THEY
HAVE. SO WE NEED TO THINK AND
TALK ABOUT THAT TOO- BUT THAT
THEY ARE ABLE TO IDENTIFY THE
STUDENTS WHO ARE IN NEED AND- I
MEAN THIS WAS A PROBLEM BEFORE
COPAYS. IT'S JUST GOTTEN WORSE.
MUCH WORSE WITH CODED. AND I
WOULD ALSO WANT TO POINT OUT
THAT- SHE DOES A STUDY PUBLISHED
IN PEDIATRICS THAT LOOKED AT-
JUST TO JUST GET A SENSE OF THE
MAGNITUDE- THAT ESTIMATED THAT
AS OF LAST JUNE- WE'VE HAD A
HUNDRED FORTY THOUSAND CHILDREN
IN THIS COUNTRY WHO HAVE LOST A
PARENT OR GRANDPARENT CAREGIVER.
SO JUST TALK ABOUT LOSS IN THAT
AND THAT'S JUST THE SUB SEGMENT.
IN FACT IT'S ESTIMATED THAT- BUT
PROBABLY OVER A HUNDRED EIGHTY
THOUSAND. CHILDREN WHO HAVE LOST
A PRIMARY CRE YOU KNOW THE
SIGNIFICANCE CARE GIVER PARENT
OR GRANDPARENT PRIMARY CARE
GIVER. AND SO TO THINK ABOUT THE
MENTAL HEALTH BURDENS- DEAD
BATTERY REPRESENTS BUT THEN WE
CAN THINK ABOUT ALL THE OTHER.
CHILDREN AS WELL WHO ARE FACING
WHETHER. IT'S A RELATIVE- THEIR
SOCIAL CIRCUMSTANCES AND SO
FORTH TO THE TREMENDOUS NEED FOR
THIS BILL WE HAVE A TREMENDOUS
NEED FOR MORE OF OUR SCHOOL
STAFF. I ALSO APPRECIATE THAT
OUR VICE CHAIRS QUESTION BECAUSE
WE NEED TO BE SURE THAT OUR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS HAVE THE
SUPPORT. THAT THEY NEED BECAUSE
THERE IS SPENDING A LOT NOT ONLY
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT EDUCATE OUR
KIDS BUT IT'S IN PERSON OR
REMOTELY. BUT ALSO SPENDING OUR
MONEY ON COPING CONTROLLED WE
SURE SCHOOLS ARE SAFE AND WE
NEED TO HELP THEM OUT THERE BY
PASSING POLICIES TO HELP
TEACHERS SCHOOLS ARE SAFE. AND
THEN OF COURSE ON TOP OF THAT TO
BE SURE THEY CAN MEET OUR
CHILDREN'S NEEDS. TO DEVELOP
THAT FIVE MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES
AND OF COURSE ALSO ONE POINT OUT
THAT A CHILD WITH A MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUE THAT'S AN-
INDEMNIFIED AND UNMANAGED. IS
ALSO THE STUDENT WHO PROBABLY
ISN'T LEARNING VERY WELL IN
SCHOOL ANYWAY. SO IT IS PART OF
THE EDUCATIONAL MISSION I
BELIEVE OF SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND
TEACHERS TO IDENTIFY CHILDREN
WITH MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES AND.
WE NEED TO BE SURE THAT THEY ARE
TRAINED TO DO SO WITH THAT- AND-
REALLY APPRECIATE LEADERSHIP
CENTER PORTANTINO- REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT I DIDN'T
ACTUALLY HAVE TO PRESENT THE
BILL BECAUSE HE'S MUCH MORE
ELOQUENT THAN I AM- BUT
CERTAINLY IN VERY STRONG SUPPORT
OF THE BILL. AND AND DOES THAT
AND REALLY- HOPE THAT WE CAN
HAVE UNANIMOUS VOTE FOR THIS
BILL COMING OUT OF THIS
COMMITTEE THANK YOU. OKAY SO
MUCH UP FOR THOSE POWERFUL
STATISTICS AS WELL CENTER PAN
VERY GRATEFUL FOR THAT. WE ARE
NOW GOING TO GO REMOTELY IN
CHECK IN WITH CENTER DOLLY GOOD
MORNING SIR. GOOD MORNING. GOOD
MORNING DOUG I JUST WANT TO
THANK THE SENATOR FOR BRINGING
THIS BACK- YOU KNOW LAST YEAR
WELL I ASKED FOR FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS TO GO TO MENTAL
HEALTH AND- AND YOU CARRIED THE
TORCH I GOT MINE GOT HUNG UP IN
APPROACH BUT I JUST WANT TO SAY
THAT SOME. I EXPERIENCED A- A
CHANGE N IN MY DAUGHTER JUST-
WHEN SHE WAS NOT ATTENDING
SCHOOL I SAW. AT HOME- AND SO
THAT'S WHERE I WAS FIRST LIKE.
REALIZING THAT YOU KNOW THE
PANDEMIC HAS. CHANGED A LOT OF
THINGS BUT I THINK IT'S BEEN
THERE ALL ALONG IN THIS. THIS
BILL- WHICH I'M HAPPY TO SUPPORT
IS GOING TO ALLOW MAYBE THE BUS
DRIVER FOR THE- FOOD SERVICE
PERSON DO YOU KNOW BE TRAINED TO
THAT SEES THOSE. CHEESY A
DIFFERENT SIDE DIDN'T- WHAT THE
PARENTS OR OTHER PEOPLE BUT I
AGREE WITH THAT SENATOR GLAZERS
THAT IT DOES TAKE A COMMUNITY
UNDERSTAND THIS ISSUE WE'VE ALL
BEEN TOUCHED BY. SOMEONE TAKING
THEIR LIVES AND IT'S A VERY
UNFORTUNATE SO VERY HAPPY TO
SUPPORT YOU WILL BE LOOKING
FORWARD TO SUPPORTING. ON THE
BUDGET COMMITTEE SOME RESOURCES
TO GO ALONG WITH THIS- SHOULD
REPORT YOU KNOW AND- I THANK YOU
FOR BRING THE STOCK BACK I
APPRECIATE IT. REALLY GREAT
WORDS THANK YOU SO MUCH. TO THE
SENATOR FOR BEAVER FOR THOSE. WE
HAD TO EACH OF THE SENATORS THE
COMMITTEE SPEAK ON THIS BILL WE
CURRENTLY HAVE A MOTION. BY
SENATOR GLAZERS ON THE DETAIL OF
SB THREE EIGHTY SEVEN. CENTER
PORTANTINO WE'RE GOING TO TURN
OVER TO YOU FOR THE CLOSE. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK YOU-
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR YOUR FOR
YOUR COMMENTS AND- WE DO WANT TO
GIVE A SPECIAL I WANT TO GIVE
SPECIAL RECOGNITION TO DR FAN.
NOW HE WAS AT THE FOREFRONT OF
THIS ISSUE- AND IT WAS
UNFORTUNATE THAT THAT BILL WAS
VETOED- WHAT THREE YEARS AGO- WE
WOULDN'T BE IN THIS SITUATION
HAVE. HAD THAT NOT HAPPENED AND-
YOU KNOW DR PANDA'S BEEN A
TIRELESS ADVOCATE FOR THIS ISSUE
AND- I'M HAPPY TO CALL MY FRIEND
AND A PARTNER. IN. THIS IN THIS
ENDEAVOR- IMPACTOR KIDS IT'S
GOING TO- WE GOT TO DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN. HERNANDEZ
SENATOR GLAZER TALKED. YOUR
MENTAL HEALTH. IT'S EVERY FAMILY
IT'S EVERY DEMOGRAPHIC SUICIDE
IT'S EVERY FAMILY EVERY
DEMOGRAPHIC EVERY GENERATION
THIS IS NOT SOMETHING THAT'S
ISOLATED AND WE REALLY HAVE TO
RALLY TOGETHER TO DO WHAT WE CAN
DO TO SHEPHERD OUR CHILDREN
THROUGH THIS DIFFICULT TIME. AND
YOU KNOW I'M HOPEFUL THAT WE CAN
GET IT THROUGH THE ASSEMBLY- I'M
HOPEFUL THEY HEAR THE APPEAL
THEY SEE THE BIPARTISAN SENSE OF
BIPARTISANSHIP BEHIND THIS
ISSUE- IT'S STRONG IT'S REAL AND
IT'S EARNEST- AND I'M HOPEFUL WE
CAN. ADDRESS CONCERNS THAT HAVE
BEEN EXPRESSED- AND WE CAN MEET
OUR FINANCIAL OBLIGATIONS AS
WELL SO WITH THAT I APPRECIATE
THE COMMITTEES- SENSITIVITY TO
THE ISSUE IN SUPPORT AND
RESPECTFULLY ASTRONOMICAL THANK
YOU SO MUCH INTO PORTANTINO THE
MOTION ON THE FLOOR BY SENATOR
GLAZERS A DO PASS BUT FIRST HE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS FOR INTERVIEW
CHIEF CONSULTANT TO BE A TO READ
THE MOTION ONCE AGAIN AND CALL
THE ROLL SOBRE. FILE ITEM NUMBER
THREE SB THREE EIGHTY SEVEN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR LEYVA.
SENATOR LEYVA S. B. THREE
EIGHTY. HI LEYVA FIVE OTOBO.
SENATOR BLOW AT SPEEDS BE EIGHTY
SEVEN. CHAU ABOVE COURTESY HI
FOR TWO HI TALLY. DALLY SB THREE
EIGHT SEVEN HI L. A. R. A.
GLAZER HI GLAZER AYE MCGUIRE
ACQUIRE AYE PAN HI AND I SEVEN.
THAT IS A SEVEN IS ZERO VOTE
SEVEN ZERO VOTE THE BILL IS OUT
WE'RE CLOSING THE ROLE THANK YOU
SO MUCH CHAMBERS THANK YOU SAN
PORTANTINO FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND
GET D. HERE TODAY IT CAN ARRIVE
MOVE FORWARD BEFORE YET LAYS IN
GERMAN WE'RE GONNA BE GOING TO
OUR LAST BILL- THE MORNING AT
LEAST FOR THIS HEARING IN THIS
IS SB FIVE SEVENTY NINE BY
SENATOR ALLEN WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR
HIS WORK ON THIS CRITICAL ISSUE.
SENATE ALLEN WE ALSO ON BEHALF
OF THE COMMITTEE WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE OF
LIKE YOU FOR LINES INTO ROCK TO
BE A TO PROCEED HERE EARLIER THE
FLOOR IS YOUR SERVER ON SB FIVE
SEVENTY NINE THANK. YOU THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR. I LET ME LET
ME JUST FIRST BY- I IT RETURNING
BE COMMON MADE BY. CURRENT
CHAIR. AS A AS THE- PAST CHAIR
OF THIS WONDERFUL COMMITTEE. HI
I HAD THE OPTION TO WORK VERY
CLOSELY WITH BRANDON I THINK WE
ACTUALLY HIRED HIM- WE BROUGHT
HIM IN WHEN I WAS CHAIR. AND I
WAS JUST SAD TO HEAR THAT HE'S
LEAVING THE COMMITTEE COURSE FOR
KEEPING HIM IN THE CAPITAL
FAMILY OVER ITS- ALLEGED COUNCIL
BUT- BUT WHAT AT WHAT IS A GOOD
PERSON A SMART PERSON VERY
DILIGENT. HI WE'RE GONNA WE'RE
GONNA MISS HIS WORK I JUST WANT
TO PERSONALLY EXPRESS MY OWN
GRATITUDE TO HIM. FOR HIS
SERVICE TO THIS SITE IS VERY
IMPORTANT COMMITTEE THE WORKING
WITH THIS COMMITTEE SO. THANK
YOU BRANDON AND ARE YOU
LISTENING IN. EVEN THE IN THE
BILL. THERE SO LET ME- LET ME
JUST START BY- BY. AS THE
CHAIRING AND CAN COMMITTEES I
WAS ABLE TO REVIEW THE ANALYSIS
IS RIGHT IF WE GET THE BABY TO
BED LAST NIGHT SO I THINK UNION
FOR THE- A GOOD ANALYSIS. ARE
YOU KNOW AS AS YOU KNOW THE KOBE
NINETEEN PANDEMIC HAS HAD A
MASSIVE IMPACT ON EVERY FACET OF
OUR LIVES SPECIAL EDUCATION
SYSTEM INDEED A NUMBER OF THE
BILLS WE HEARD TODAY HAVE
ALLUDED TO THAT FACT HI IN THE
LAST TWO YEARS OUR SCHOOLS HAVE
PIVOTED FROM VIRTUAL LEARNING TO
HYBRID LEARNING FACING SHIFTING
ENROLLMENT STAFFING SHORTAGES.
YEAH I KNOW THAT IN MY SENATE
DISTRICT LIKE IN SO MANY OF
YOURS- SO MANY SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
HAVE CONCERNS THAT A ROLE AND
WILL CONTINUE TO SHIFT IN
UNPREDICTABLE WAYS IMPACTING
THEIR FUNDING EVEN IF THE IN
RESPONSE. TO INCREASED STUDENT
NEEDS. IN RESPONSE THE PANDEMIC
ATTENDANCE LEVELS WHICH
DETERMINE THE BULK OF FUNDING
UNDER THE LCF OFF HAVE BEEN
FROZEN SINCE TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
OUR TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE- TO
CURB THE IMPACT- ON OUR SCHOOLS
THIS BILL. SB FIVE SEVEN NINE
WOULD FREE SCHOOL DISTRICT
EIGHTY EIGHT FOR AN ADDITIONAL
YEAR AS WE CONTINUE BROADER
DISCUSSIONS ON WHAT SCHOOL
FUNDING LOOKS LIKE IN THE FUTURE
PROVIDING SOME CERTAINTY FOR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AS THEY PLAN
THEIR SPENDING STAFFING AND
PROGRAMS AHEAD. OF THE BUDGET
ADOPTION AND SOME YOU KNOW I WAS
A SCHOOL BOARD MEMBER MYSELF I
CAN ONLY WE WENT THROUGH THE
DIFFICULTIES OF THE TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT- ECONOMIC CRISIS
INCREDIBLY DIFFICULT TO PLAN AND
KEEP THE LIGHTS ON IN THE
DISTRICT DIED DURING THOSE
UNCERTAINTIES. NOW BUT AT THAT
TIME- THE UNCERTAINTIES ARE ONLY
BASED ON THE FINANCES FROM THE
STATE AS DIFFICULT AS I WAS NOW
WE HAVE THIS WHOLE NEW
UNCERTAINTY ASSOCIATED WITH A
PANDEMIC IT'S SO COMPLICATED I
KNOW YOUR SCHOOL DISTRICTS FEEL
THIS WAY. THAT'S WHY WE GOT THE
STRONG SUPPORT OF SCHOOL BOARD
MEMBERS AND DISTRICT ALL UP AND
DOWN THE STATE FOR THIS BILL
INCLUDING THE CSPA AND HERE WITH
ME TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. OUR STEVEN COLLEGES AND
JOHNSON FROM THE HERMOSA. YOUR
WORK ON SB FIVE SEVENTY NINE ALL
RIGHT LAZY JIM WOOD TO LEAD
WITNESSES- EASILY WITNESSES WILL
BE PROVIDED TWO MINUTES AND
WE'LL GIVE THEM A THIRTY SECOND
PROMPT WE'RE GONNA START WITH
MISTER MCCALL UP REPRESENTING
THE HERMOSA BEACH UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT MISTER MCCALL YOUR
LIGHTING COMMITTEE NOW. PLEASE
PROCEED IT'LL GIVE YOU A THIRTY
SECOND PROMPT. MORNING CHAT AND
EDUCATION COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
THANK YOU FOR GIVING ME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THE SB FIVE SEVENTY
NINE. THE SAFETY MICHAEL AND I'M
A BOARD MEMBER OF IMMEDIATE PAST
PRESIDENT OF THE HERMOSA BEACH
CITY SCHOOL DISTRICT. WE'VE BEEN
WORKING CLOSELY WITH SENATOR
ALAN TRYING TO CONSULATE THAT
WILL SUPPORT SCHOOL DISTRICTS
LARGE AND SMALL ACROSS
CALIFORNIA AS WE DEAL WITH THE
IMPACTS OF CLIMATE NINETEEN.
MOST OF BEACH IS THE SMALLEST
SCHOOL DISTRICT IN L. A. COUNTY%
. AT THE START OF THE PANDEMIC
WE WILL HEAD WITH 12% ON
ENROLLMENT. LAST WEEK WITH A
MICRON ARE ADA DROPPED 13% OVER
THE PAST FEW YEARS WE'VE HAD TO
MAKE CUTS TO US SOFT THAT
INCLUDED FULL TIME LIBRARIANS.
COUNSELORS AND ALIMENTARY IN
MIDDLE SCHOOL. JUST WANT TO SING
CAN. PUBLIC SCHOOL IN CALIFORNIA
WHERE WE DIED CHILDREN DIED EVEN
HAVE A LIBRARIAN. SOMEONE TO
TALK TO FOR MENTAL HEALTH
SUPPORTS. AS WE KNOW WITH
OMICRON WE'RE FAR FROM OUT OF
THE WOODS ON THIS PANDEMIC. WE
NEED SB FIVE SEVENTY NINE. SO
THAT WE CAN NAVIGATE THE
CONTINUED PENTOMIC COMPOUND
LONGER TERM WITHOUT FISCAL
CLIFFS. INDEED WE RECOGNIZE THAT
THE LONG TERM SUCCESS OF
EDUCATION IS NOT ONE
DIMENSIONAL. AN INCREASE TO BASE
FUNDING IN A MULTITUDE OF OTHER
FACTORS WILL BE CRITICAL.
WITHOUT SB FIVE SEVENTY NINE WE
WILL STRUGGLE TO MEET THE NEEDS
OF ALL STUDENTS WELL IN THIS
TIME TO MAKE. I BELIEVE THAT ALL
DISTRICTS SMALL AND LARGE ARE IN
THE SAME PREDICAMENT. WE WANT TO
PROVIDE THE MOST BRILLIANT
EDUCATION ACCOUNTABLE ALL
STUDENTS. I NEED FINANCIAL SAID
SOMETHING TO DO SO THIRTY
SECONDS. I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU
ON A PRODUCT. THANK YOU THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR SO CALLED THANK
YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE TO THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT- KIDS WE'RE
GRATEFUL THAT YOU WOULD BE
WILLING CALLING TODAY WE'RE NOT
GONNA BE TURNING OVER. TO JASON
JOHNSON JASON ALSO IS WITH THE
HERMOSA BEACH UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT MISTER JOHNSON YOU ARE
NOW LIVE IN COMMITTEE YOU HAVE
TWO MINUTES I'LL GIVE YOU A
THIRTY SECOND PROMPT PLEASE
PROCEED. THE MORNING CARE AND
EDUCATION COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS DR JASON JOHNSON I'M
SUPERINTENDENT FOR MOST OF EACH
CITY SCHOOL DISTRICT HERE TO
OFFER MY SUPPORT. OF SB FIVE
SEVENTY NINE. NINE I WILL BE
PRESENTING TO OUR BOARD OF
EDUCATION THAT KOBE NINETEENTH
DECLINING ENROLLMENT AND
FINANCIAL UNCERTAINTY. HAS
BECOME AN EXISTENTIAL THREAT TO
OUR SMALL SCHOOL DISTRICT. AND
OTHER SMALL SCHOOL DISTRICTS
ACROSS PUBLIC EDUCATION.
FOLLOWING THE START OF THE
PANDEMIC MOST OF EACH SAW THE
LAW TECH IN ENROLLMENT IN OVER A
HUNDRED YEARS. I KNOW THAT MANY
OTHER SCHOOL DISTRICTS BIG AND
SMALL THROUGHOUT THE STATE
EXPERIENCED SIMILAR HOW
DYSTROPHIC DECLINES. THIS IS
EXACERBATED BY OUR SYSTEMS
RELIANCE ON ATTENDANCE TO
DETERMINE FUNDING WHICH HAS BEEN
INCONSISTENT AT BEST THROUGHOUT
THE AND THAT PANDEMIC. WE ARE
COMMITTED TO BUILDING BACK
BETTER WE SUPPORT NOW IN PLACE
YOU PRIVATE FUNDING GRANTS
SUPPORT OUR STUDENTS MENTAL
HEALTH AND WELLNESS AS WELL AS
ACADEMIC EXCELLENCE FOR ALL.
HOWEVER THE LONG TERM SUCCESS WE
NEED CERTAINTY AND ARE FINDING
OVER THE COMING YEAR. SB FIVE
SEVENTY NINE WILL PROVIDE THAT
CERTAINTY BY EXTEND THE HOLD
HARMLESS PROVISION AND
SUPPORTING SCHOOL DISTRICTS
ACROSS THE STATE. FOR ADDITIONAL
YEAR. AND AS WE CONTINUE
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THE FUTURE
OF EDUCATION FUNDING IN
CALIFORNIA. WE NEED TO CONTINUE
OUR WORK OF RECOVERY IN TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE WE NEED AT THE
STATE SUPPORT NOW MORE THAN EVER
TO CONTINUE THIS WORK. FOR THESE
REASONS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. BOATS AND I'M HERE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT
HAVE THANK YOU. THAN YOU SO
MUCH THIS IS SUPERINTENDENT PC
TO PHONE CALL HERE TODAY- THE
SUPERINTENDENT AND THE BOARD
MEMBER WILL BE. HOLDING STEADY
AS WE HAVE THIS CONVERSATION ON
SB FIVE SEVENTY NINE THOSE ARE
TO LEAD SUPPORT WITNESSES WERE
NOT GOING TO SEE IF THERE'S
ANYONE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
HERE IN ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE.
SENIOR ONES STAND LAYS IN GERMAN
THAT'S THAT'S RIGHT WE'RE GOING
TO THE LIVE LINE WE'RE GONNA GO
TO THE TELECONFERENCE LINE ONE
MORE TIME HERE FOR ONE MORE
BILL. CHECKING WITH THE
MODERATOR MISTER MODERATOR THAT
THAT'S QUEUE UP ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHO IS IN SUPPORT OF SB. FIVE
SEVENTY NINE NOW. THANK YOU
MISTER IF YOU LIKE TO SEARCH
IT'S A OF THIS. PLEASE PRESS
THEN ZERO AT THIS. GO TO LINE
FORTY. PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS ERICA HOFFMAN ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
BOARDS ASSOCIATION VERY MUCH IN
SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE THANK YOU
GOOD TO HEAR YOUR VOICE HEARD.
THANK YOU SO MUCH THAT'S GOING
TO OUR NEXT CALLER. AND NEXT A
LITTLE LINE FOURTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS AN
EVALUATIVE CALLING ON BEHALF OF
GREEN THAT PUBLIC SCHOOL
CALIFORNIA WE SUPPORT SENATE
BILL FIVE SEVENTY NINE IF IT IS
AMENDED TO ENSURE EIGHTY A HOLD
HARMLESS PROTECTION FOR ALL
SCHOOLS AND AT TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO FISCAL YEAR. I THINK
I'M- AB EIGHT LOSSES THIS YEAR
DUE TO CONDEMN LATEST DIDN'T
HAPPEN THANK YOU SO MUCH CRAP
ARE NINETEEN REALLY. FEAR OPCO.
I NEED A LOT OF NINE DOLLARS
MODERATE. THANK YOU SO IS ONE OF
REMIND FOR. THAT WERE AT. FOR IF
YOU HAVE CAN EXPRESSED CONCERNS
BUT WE'RE GOING TO ASK FIRST AND
LAST NAME. THE ORGANIZATION IN
YOUR POSITION ON THE BILL AND I
DO APPRECIATE THAT THANK YOU SO
MUCH MISTER MODERATOR THAT'S GO
TO OUR NEXT CALLER. ACTUALLY
HAVE LINE FIFTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS THERE ABOUT
THE THEFT OF A LONG BEHALF OF
LOS ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT WE'RE PLEASED TO
SUPPORT SB FIVE SEVEN NINE. THE
PHONE CALL TODAY THANK YOU SO
MUCH THAT'S GOOD OR AN EXCELLENT
. NEXT WE HAVE LINED FORTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
THIS IS TRACY MILER'S ARE KEEN
ON THE BOARD PRESIDENT FOR THE
SMALL BUT MIGHTY AND A UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF SB. FIVE SEVEN NINE
IN THE ON GOING AND- THANK YOU
ALL FOR YOUR TIME TO. AND FOR
YOUR SERVER. THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR THE PRESIDENT BY CATCH UP.
CALLED LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. NEXT TO THE ONE
FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING AND WE CAN WATCH
CHILDREN REPRESENTING THE SAN
DIEGO UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SENATOR ALAN. SHE TO PHONE CALL
TODAY THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. LINE THIRTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS DAN SEYMOUR AND I AM THE VICE
PRESIDENT OF THE PALISADES
ANGELA HILLS HIGH SCHOOL
DISTRICT WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF SB
FIVE SEVEN NINE THANK YOU SO
MUCH YOU CAN MINIMIZE PRISON
APPRECIATE YOUR PHONE CALL LET'S
GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER. LINE
THIRTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS BETTY JIM LET
ME FIRST SAY THAT I APPRECIATE
THE WORK THAT YOU'RE HONORABLE
BODY DOES THANK YOU VERY MUCH MY
HUSBAND WAS A FORMER STATE
SENATOR. BUT I'M HERE TESTIFYING
AS A SCHOOL BOARD MEMBER AND
IMMEDIATE PAST PRESIDENT OF THE
TORRANCE UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
SENATOR ALAN BILL BECAUSE IT
ENSURES THAT WE HAVE THE FUNDING
WE NEED TO SUPPORT OUR OVER
TWENTY THREE THOUSAND STUDENTS
AND THANK YOU SEE TOMORROW HE
HOOKED. AND STAFF DURING THE
UNDERLINGS PANDEMIC ALL RIGHT
NEVER SPECIALLY NOW WE
APPRECIATE THAT MODERATOR GONNA
BE GOING TO OUR NEXT CALLER AND
DO APOLOGIZE YOU ALL FOR JUST
TRYING TO BE FAIR TO EVERYONE SO
JUST ONE REMIND FOLKS HERE
CALLING WITH HERE IN SUPPORT OR
PLEASE STATE YOUR FIRST AND LAST
NAME THE ORGANIZATION YOUR
POSITION ON THE BILL WE JUST
WANT TO BE FAIR AND EQUITABLE TO
ALL CALLERS WHO ARE CALLING IN.
AND PROVIDE THAT SAME SERVICE IN
TIME THANK YOU CAN MISS CHEN FOR
YOUR PHONE CALL IN FOR YOUR
SERVICES WELL LET'S GO TO OUR
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. WE GO TO
LINE FORTY TWO GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME JAMES HAHN AND I UP
PRESIDENT OF THE POINTS SCHOOL
DISTRICT BOARD AND WE AREN'T THE
OF SB FIVE THIRTY NINE THANK YOU
BYE ALLEN FOR MAKING THIS BILL
POSSIBLE. THANK YOU FOR SERVICE
SIR THANK YOU MUCH SIS RIGHT
NEXT. WE ARE ONE FORTY THREE
FISCAL. HI I AM PL THE PUTT OF
THE BORDER TRUSTEES AT MANHATTAN
BEACH UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF SB FIVE
SEVENTY NINE THANK YOU SENATOR
ALLEN AND THANKS TO ALL OF YOU.
REALLY APPRECIATE A PHONE CALL
HERE TODAY LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER. EMISSARY HAVE NO ONE
ELSE IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME
REALLY APPRECIATED THANK YOU MR
MODERATOR ALL RIGHT LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN WE DO NOT HAVE ANY
LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESSES ON
RECORD HERE TODAY. SO WE'RE
GOING TO SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE
IN ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE. WHO'D
LIKE TO BE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB FIVE SEVENTY
NINE C. KNOWN RISE LAYS GERMAN
FOR THE FINAL TIME TODAY WE'RE
GONNA BE CHECKING IN. WITH THE
MODERATOR MR MODERATOR THANK YOU
FOR ALL YOUR WORK TODAY THAT'S
QUEUE UP ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO MAY
BE IN OPPOSITION OF SB FIVE
SEVENTY NINE NOW. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. IF YOU'D LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF THIS
LEGISLATION PLEASE PRESS ONE
BUTTON ZERO AT THIS TIME. MR WE
HAVE KNOWN SHOOTING UP AT THIS
TIME ALL RIGHT THANK YOU SO MUCH
AS A MODERATOR APPRECIATED WE DO
HAVE A- QUESTION COMING FROM
CENTER PAN BUT LET'S START WITH.
I CENTER LEYVA WE'RE GOING TO GO
CENTER LEYVA CENTER PAN IN INTO
THE VICE CHAIR CENTER LABOR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH CENTER
MOBILE WATER I JUST WANNA THINK
CENTER ALLEN FOR. BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD IT'S INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT THAT WE HELP OUR
SCHOOLS IN ANY WAY WE CAN. AND A
BILL LIKE THIS WITH THE HOME
HOLD HARMLESS PROVISION IS VERY
IMPORTANT. I WILL HAVE TO MAKE
SOME BIG DECISIONS IN THE FUTURE
BUT FOR THE SHORT TERM THIS IS
THE RIGHT MOVE. THANK YOU CENTER
ALLEN. THANK YOU SENATOR FOR ALL
YOUR WORK ON THIS BILL ALONG
WITH YOUR VERY CAPABLE STAFF IS
WELL THANK YOU SO MUCH THAT'S GO
TO CENTER PAN THEN THE VICE
CHAIR CENTER PAN. THANKS VERY
MUCH AND CENTER ALLEN I DO
APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD AND CERTAINLY. AND
AS WE'RE DEALING THE CODE CRISIS
AND- UNCERTAINTY REGARDIG
ENROLLMENT- DO WE NEED TO
ADDRESS THAT. I GUESS IT TOO
QUESTIONS PERHAPS YOU CAN
ADDRESS- SO. TO ONE IS THAT- HOW
DOES THIS BILL CORRESPOND TO
WHAT THE GOVERNOR PROPOSED IN
THE BUDGET IN TERMS OF. HOW TO
ADDRESS- THE- IN TERMS OF- FUND
THE SCHOOL FUNDING SO ON JUST
ONE TO KNOW IF THERE ARE- HOW
THIS BILL AND PUT GOVERNOR
PROPOSED COUNTY CORRESPOND OR
NOT CORRESPOND. AND IN THE
SECOND QUESTION IS THAT. FIVE
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THAT- THAT
NOW THERE'S A NEED FOR THIS- BUT
ALSO MAKE NOTE THE ANALYSIS
POINTS OUT THAT YOU KNOW THE-
THIS GUMMIES I GUESS THE THIRD
YEAR HI FINANCIALLY. AT SOME
POINT WE GOTTA FIGURE A START
HAVING SOME CONVERSATION ABOUT
HOW TO. NOTE SO WE GOT FREEZER
FOREVER OR WE GONNA FIND SOME
AND YES WE ARE TO BILLS COOK OF
THE CRISIS AND THERE'S A LOT OF
UNCERTAINTY SO I GET THAT. SO IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL BUT WE ALSO
NEED TO START HAVING SOME KIND
OF CONVERSATION ABOUT WHAT IS
THE- ESSENTIALLY THE OFF RAMP.
TO THIS THAT CAN DEBT THAT WOULD
REFLECT- STILL WE CAN RESET YOUR
HOW TO BE STABLE- THE FINANCING
SO- YOU KNOW YOU HAVE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ARE GROWING YOUR
SCHOOL OTHER SCHOOL DISTRICTS
ARE SHRINKING. WE'RE NOT SURE
WHETHER TO GROWING L. SOME
BECAUSE THIS BILL MOVEMENT
PEOPLE IN THE STATE. CLEARLY WE
HAVE ISSUES IN TERMS OF ROMAN
BECAUSE OF COVETED OF THAT SORT
OF THE- THE PART THAT THEY ARE
THE WILD CARDS THAT WERE
STUDENTS SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE
DEALING WITH MOST IMPORTANTLY.
THAT WE'RE DEALING WITH BUT
EVENTUALLY AT SOME POINT IN TIME
WE'VE GOT TO FIGURE OUT WHAT THE
OFFRAMP IS SO. PERHAPS YOU CAN
ALSO TOUCH ON. A WELCOME
DISCUSSIONS ARE TAKING PLACE TO
DATE THAT YOU'RE AWARE OF OR IF
THERE ARE CONVERSATIONS THAT-
WE'RE ENGAGING IN IN TERMS OF.
FIGURING OUT SOME KIND OF AN OFF
RAMP SO THAT WE'RE JUST NOT.
EXTENDING THIS YEAR AFTER YEAR
AFTER YEAR. BECAUSE YOU KNOW THE
MORE YEARS IT'S EXTENDED THE
MORE CHALLENGING GETS AND ALSO
THE MORE. YOU KNOW THIRTY FRANK
YOU CAN ADD THAT- YOURS ARE
FREEZING SOMETHING IN PLACE THAT
OVER TIME MAY CAUSE MORE
PROBLEMS AS WELL SO. AGAIN
SUPPORTING THIS BILL TODAY IT'S
A NECESSARY THING WE NEED TO DO
BUT WE ALSO AND THIS BEING YOUR
THREE WE NEED TO START HAVING
THOSE CONVERSATIONS. WELL VERY
MUCH A- THE- CENTER. I'M I WAS
THE- DID SOMETHING OUT ABOUT A
THREE YEAR ROLLING EDA AVERAGE
ON THE SCHOOL FUNDING BUT OF
COURSE. NOTHING IS CONFIRMED-
THAT'S JUST HIS PROPOSAL RIGHT-
SO FOR US I THINK THE IDEA IS
THAT THE EXTENDING HOLD HARMLESS
REMAINS AN IMPORTANT NEAR FUTURE
SOLUTION TO GIVE SCHOOLS- SOME
CERTAINTY AS THEY PLAN THEIR
FINANCES IN THEIR PROGRAMS- BUT-
YOU KNOW I RESERVE RESPECT I. I
GUESS I WOULD TURN IT BACK TO
YOU AS A RESIDENT IMMUNOLOGIST-
ARE YOU THIS IS ALL ABOUT
BECAUSE OF IT RIGHT I MEAN I YOU
KNOW. I TOTALLY I WOULD NEVER
BRING A BILL LIKE THIS BOARD. IF
WE SAW- IF IT WEREN'T FOR THE
PANDEMIC RIGHT AND WHAT WE DID
THE PANDEMIC IT JUST REEKS.
HAVOC ON ENROLLMENT. PROJECTIONS
NUMBERS- IT'S SO DIFFICULT FOR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO UNDERSTAND.
WHAT'S HAPPENING BUT THERE'S NO
QUESTION THIS OUGHT TO BE IS
SOMETHING THAT THE THIS
COMMITTEE DISCUSSES THE STUDENT
SUCCESS LET COMMITTEE- THE
BUDGET SUB I MEAN THAT YOU KNOW
THAT THIS IS ARE WE GOTTA GET
OUR HANDS AROUND I GUESS I. THE
HOPE CONTINUES TO BEING THAT WE
GET. THAT THE BY AND BY THE TIME
BY BY NEXT YEAR- WHAT WE WILL
HAVE A MUCH BETTER SENSE OF
WHERE. THIS IS ALL GOING AND NOT
NOT ONLY AND YOU. HAVE ANY
LOGICALLY SOCIETALLY AND THEN
AND THEN OF COURSE. WHAT THAT
MEANS FOR SCHOOL DISTRICT
ENROLLMENT- I MEAN FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE I IT SOUNDS LIKE YOU
AGREE THIS IS THIS IS JUST A
WISE. WAY FOR US TO JUST
CONTINUE WITH THE FUNDING AS
OTHERWISE BECAUSE WE ALL KNOW
THAT SCHOOL DISTRICTS. CONTINUE
TO HAVE ENORMOUS- CHALLENGES IS
KEEPING YOUR KEEPING THE PROGRAM
STRONG AND LIGHTS ON- AND AS WE
TRY TO FIGURE OUT WHERE THIS IS
GOING AND WHAT IMPACT IT'S GOING
TO HAVE IN A ROMAN. BUT I YOU
KNOW I LOVE I MEAN I THINK THAT
IT. YES I WOULD JUST SUGGEST
THAT THIS IS SOMETHING THAT THIS
COMMITTEE OUGHT TO SPEND SOME
TIME LOOKING OUT IN THE
INTRODUCTION OF THE BUDGET SEVEN
I LOVE YOU FOR THIS DISCUSSION.
OKAY SO I APPRECIATE THE A
BECAUSE YOU'RE THE AUTHOR OF THE
VEHICLE FOR APPS THAT WE CAN
HAVE SOME OF THIS QUESTION ABOUT
SO- APPRECIATE YOUR- THAT YOUR
LEADERSHIP. AND- ADDRESSING THIS
. CLEAR THIS. DICK THE WHILE
CARD IS COATED IN- WE- THE IN.
IS IT'S IMPORTANT FOR. TO PASS
POLICY TO ENSURE KIDS ARE. AT
SCHOOL BECAUSE PART OF THE-
PARENTS AREN'T ROLLING TO. YOU
KNOW THE BIG IMPACT. AND SO IT'S
A- THAT WE- THE POLICY. SO THAT
PEOPLE HAVE CONFIDENCE. WHEN THE
KIDS ARE IN SCHOOL THEY'RE SAFE.
AND SO THAT'S GOING TO BE
ANOTHER CERTAINLY WORK FOR US AS
WELL HOPEFULLY PROVIDING MORE
CERTAINTY THERE FOR TWO SCHOOL
DISTRICTS IN THE FUTURE. BUT I
ALSO JUST WANTED A KNOWLEDGE THE
SAP ANALYSIS WHERE- WELL WE ARE
TRYING TO DEAL IN THE KEEP
SITUATION IN THE LONG TERM WE
ALSO NOT. NOT NEED TO THINK
ABOUT. IT WILL LIKELY A FISCAL
CLIFF AND WHERE PEOPLE ARE
AFRAID TO SAY WELL. WE'LL GET
THIS FREEZE THINGS BECAUSE WE'RE
AFRAID THE FISCAL CLIFF SO WE
YOU KNOW THE LONGER DRAGS OUT
THE MORE CHALLENGING AS SO. BUT
IF. YOU'RE LEADERSHIP AND BE
HAPPY TO MOVE THE BILL AT THIS
POINT IN TIME THANK YOU THANK
YOU SO MUCH CENTER PAN CENTER
PAN HAS A MOTION ON THE FLOOR
WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE WITH
COMMITTEE CONVERSATION WE HAVE.
THE VICE CHAIR THAN CENTER DAHLE
IN CENTER GLAZER MEADOW VICE
CHAIR THE FLOOR IS YOURS. THE
SIDE. HERE THANK YOU SO MUCH SIR
DOLLARS. THE FOR YOUR CENTER
DOLLARS THANK YOU CAN YOU HEAR
ME OK THERE WE GOTTA COME INTO
LINE KLINGBERG. SO FIRST OFF I
JUST WANT TO SAY I'M- YOU KNOW
I'VE VOTED FOR- AUSPICES IN THE
LAST COUPLE OF CYCLES BUT TIGHT.
I'VE ALSO BEEN DOING SOME
HOMEWORK BEEN TALKING TO- AT
LEAST IN MY DISTRICT THE
SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS AND
ALSO BEEN TALKING TO- PARENTS
AND TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHAT IS
REALLY HAPPENING OUT THERE IS IT
AND I I'M TRYING TO BE A
SPRINGBOARD OFF OF. US SENATOR
PAN'S QUESTIONS- AND I THINK WE
NEED TO HAVE A DEEPER
CONVERSATION AND JUST CONTINUING
TO- YOU KNOW FIND. ADA AT THE
LEVEL IT WAS PRIOR TO THE
PANDEMIC. IN THAT WHY SAY THAT
IS THAT I DON'T BELIEVE IN THIS
BILL WE DON'T TAKE CARE CHARTER
SCHOOLS. AND A LOT OF THE
DISTRICTS THAT- I REPRESENT. A
LOT OF THEIR STUDENTS LEFT NOT
BECAUSE OF. THE PANDEMIC IN
BEING SAFE. BECAUSE OF THE
POLICIES OF HOW THEY WERE
CHILDREN ARE BEING TAUGHT. AND I
THINK THAT WE SEE THAT IN. THE
LA UNIFIED WERE- YOU KNOW YOU
CAN YOU TO ALLOW- EIGHTY EIGHT
FUNDS TO COME IN AND WE DON'T
REALLY TRACK WHERE THE KIDS ARE
GOING AND WHY THEY'RE GOING
WHERE THEY'RE GOING SO I THINK
WE NEED TO HAVE A CONVERSATION.
WITH A LONGER WE CONTINUE TO
MOVE IN THIS DIRECTION- WE'RE
GONNA REALLY BE SOME SCHOOLS
PEOPLE ARE MOVING TO BECAUSE
THEIR POLICIES ARE DIFFERENT
ABOUT HOW THEY- TAKE CARE OF
COKE WHICH SO I HAVE MY ACTUAL
QUESTION IS THIS. I'M GONNA LAY
OUT THE BILL TODAY- I KNOW THE
LOT OF MY SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE
IN FAVOR OF IT THAT- THAT OF
STATE OPEN AND DONE I THINK A
GREAT GREAT JOB IN SOME OF THAT.
THAT YOU KNOW HAVE INCREASED IN
EIGHTY EIGHT BECAUSE THEIR
POLICIES ARE DIFFERENT TO- NEED
TO THEIR ADHD EXPANDED. AND I
WOULD LIKE THAT CENTER TALK
ABOUT. CHARTER SCHOOLS IF YOU
COULD IN WHITES NOT ADDRESSED IN
THIS PIECE OF LEGISLATION.
ALLENDORF FOR CENTER. QUESTION
PLEASE WHAT WILL FIRST ALL IT'S
INCORRECT TO SAY WITH DOESN'T
COVER CHARGE SCHOOL IT DOES
GOING FORWARD THE ISSUE IS HAS
TO DO WITH THE FUNDING MECHANISM
FOR CHARTER SCHOOLS. AS IT
RELATES TO THE TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. AND TRY TO THE
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO SCHOOL
YEAR. AND YOU KNOW I GUESS THERE
WAS A- I MET WITH HER SCHOOL
FOLKS YESTERDAY. AND THEY HAD A
PROPOSAL FOR SOME LANGUAGE AND
IT TURNS OUT THERE IS A BATTLE
THAT'S BEEN HAPPENING OVER THIS-FINANCING- AS IT RELATES TO- AT
THE THAT'S BEEN HAPPENING HERE
IN THIS COMMITTEE- AND YOU KNOW
THAT IT HAPPENED I GUESS AFTER I
LEFT THE TERM AND AFTER I LEFT
THE COMMITTEE. SO WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO TALK TO THEM WORK
WITH THEM IN ORDER TO COMMITTEE
STAFF TRY TO SEE IF WE CAN
FIGURE OUT A WAY TO. TO MEET
THEIR CONCERNS- YOU KNOW BUT IT
THE ABSOLUTELY INCLUDES THEM
GOING ON A GOING FORWARD BASIS
THE ISSUE THAT JUST CAME OUT
YESTERDAY FOR ME HAS TO DO. WITH
THIS FUNDING MECHANISM AS IT
RELATES TO THIS SCHOOL YEAR.
AND- YEAH WE JUST GOT A NOTE
FROM YOUR STAFF. LEO YESTERDAY
EVENING AND WE'RE JUST GONNA
HAVE TO WE'RE GOING TO SPEND
SOME TIME WORKING ON THIS- WITH
THE COMMITTEE STAFF AND
CERTAINLY INVITE YOUR
PARTICIPATION SENATOR. SENATE
ONLY A THIRD VICTIM I APPRECIATE
THAT AND I ALWAYS LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH YOU ON VERY
THOUGHTFUL AND TOUGH ISSUES THIS
IS NOT EASY- BUT I THINK
EVERYBODY NEEDS WITH THE TABLE
AND I'LL BE LOOKING FORWARD TO
AGAIN I'M A LAY OUT THE BILL
TODAY BUT I LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU TRYING TO COME
UP WITH. SOMETHING THAT WE JUST
DON'T PUSH THIS THROUGH AND WE
DO WHAT WE'VE BEEN DOING WE NEED
OUT. ACTUAL CONVERSATIONS A
BIGGER OUT. WHY WHY THE STUDENTS
ARE GOING WHERE THEY ARE A LOT
OF. CHARTER SCHOOLS- GROUP WERE
GROWING. AT A FAST PACE FOR
PUBLIC SCHOOLS WEREN'T BECAUSE
THEY WERE JUST OPEN AT THE TIME
NOW THAT COULD BE A DIFFERENT
CASE NOW THAT WAS THAT TWO YEARS
AGO. AND HERE WE ARE THE THIRD
YEAR SO LOOK FORWARD TO THE
CONVERSATION WITH YOU. SENATOR
ALAN. THANK YOU FOR THE SENATE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH SEVEN DOLLARS
FOR YOUR COMMENTS DISCONTENT
GLAZER. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
TIED TO- TWO COMMENTS ONE IS
BUT- I DO ALSO APPRECIATE THE-
POINTS THAT WERE RAISED IN THE
ANALYSIS THAT SENATOR PAN SPOKE
TO. AND YOU KNOW IT'S HARD TO BE
A SCHOOL BOARD MEMBER THESE DAYS
AND THAT NONE OF US HAVE CRYSTAL
BALLS- BUT I WILL SAY THAT
BEFORE THIS PANDEMIC EVER
HAPPENED WE HAD SCHOOL DISTRICTS
THAT WERE. ON THE BORDER OF
BANKRUPTCY BECAUSE THEY- REFUSED
TO MAKE THE HARD DECISIONS THAT
WERE NECESSARY FOR A VARIETY OF
BUDGETARY REASONS. NOT JUST
ABOUT ENROLLMENT HELLO THAT
CERTAINLY IS A- IS A DOMINANT
ONE AND THIS COMMITTEE DOESN'T
REALLY GET TO. HEAR THESE TYPES
OF ISSUES BECAUSE THEY'RE HEARD
IN BUDGET- EVEN OTHER
IMPLICATIONS FOR EDUCATION ARE
ENORMOUS. AND SO. I JUST WANT
TO. PUT A- IN IN THAT POINT
BECAUSE I THINK IT'S A GOOD ONE-
I WOULD I DO WANT TO ADDRESS THE
ISSUE OF CHARTER SCHOOLS HERE
BECAUSE YOU KNOW WE WE'VE HAD
BATTLES OVER MANY DECADES REALLY
IN THE CHARTER SCHOOL PUBLIC
SCHOOL SPACE- AND- YOU KNOW A
PART OF. PEACE IN THE SPACES
EQUITY. THAT THAT THE PEOPLE
THAT THE UNITS THAT THAT THERE'S
FAIRNESS. AND WE HAD SOME PRETTY
TOUGH BILLS A COUPLE YEARS AGO
THAT USE THAT POINT EXACTLY TO
BE CONCERNING CRITICAL UP OF THE
PUBLIC CHARTER SCHOOLS. AND THEN
YOU GET A SITUATION LIKE. TO
REPRESENTED IN THIS BILL ABOUT
FUNDING AND THAT'S A VERY
SERIOUS YOU KNOW. SITUATION FOR
EVERYONE INCLUDING THE PUBLIC
CHARTER SCHOOLS AND BY THE WAY
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIANS GOING TO THOSE
PUBLIC SCHOOLS. AND IT JUST
SEEMS TO ME THAT- THIS SHOULDN'T
BE A PLACE FOR IN EQUITY TO IT
TOO TO REAR ITS HEAD SHOULD BE
ABOUT EQUITY AND FAIRNESS. AND
SO THE EXCLUSION OF THAT YEAR
SENATOR LLEN THIS BILL IS A
VERY TROUBLING ISSUE TO ME. IS
IT IT REVISITS A FIGHT THAT I
THOUGHT WERE TRYING TO NOT HAVE-
CHARTER SCHOOLS HAPPENED.
SIGNIFICANTLY AFFECTED BY THIS
PANDEMIC WHY SHOULD THEY BE
TREATED SEPARATELY WHY. I KNOW
IT'S A QUESTION THAT YOU'RE
WRESTLING WITH MAYBE JUST
LEARNED ABOUT MORE RECENTLY BUT
IT'S A IMPORTANT WANTED THIS
SENATOR AND I'M SURE TO OTHERS
AND I HOPE THAT. IN ADVANCING
WHAT I KNOW TO BE A VERY GOOD
HAD THOUGHT FULL. LEGISLATION
THAT WE DON'T GO BACKWARDS M. HI
I HOPE THAT YOU CAN WORK ON THAT
GOING FORWARD AND ALL SUPPORT
THE BILL TODAY. PLEASE YEAH I
MEAN I'M INTERESTED IN FINDING
SOLUTION MEDICINE INCLUDING THAT
MY DIET YOU KNOW I IT I WOULD
BECAUSE I SORT OF RUN INTO THIS
- THIS ISSUE THAT CAME OUT OF
THE ORIGINAL DEAL AND THAT THIS
COMMITTEES WORKED ON AND SO I'M
I'M JUST HOPING THAT WORK. WILL
THERE'S A PATH MOVING FORWARD
WORKING WITH THE COMMITTEE
STAFF. TO FIGURE OUT A WAY TO BE
IN COMPLIANCE WITH. THE
COMMITTEE'S POSITION- WHILE
ENSURING. THE EQUITY GOALS THAT
YOU JUST ARTICULATED. THAT
CERTAINLY MY INTEREST. THANK YOU
SENATE SECRETARY ANY ITEMS IN
ORDER. THANK YOU WE HAVE MOTION
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND GLAZER FOR
THAT SECRETARY PLEASE I'M GOOD
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU SO MUCH OF
BEILEIN'S IN GENERAL WE'VE HEARD
FROM MAJORITY OF THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE
FLOOR BY SENATOR PAN ON SB FIVE
SEVENTY NINE SURROUND BURKE ASK
YOU TO PLEASE CLOSE. TO PRESERVE
ABOUT DISCUSS LOOKS TO AND
MEANINGFUL WORK WITH THIS
COMMITTEE GOING FORWARD WITH
SOME OF THE STAKEHOLDERS- BUT
ULTIMATELY THIS IS JUST ABOUT
UNITY DURING THIS THIS
UNPRECEDENTED CRAZY TIME. WHEN
SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE STRUGGLING
WITH SO MANY. SO MANY
UNCERTAINTIES- ARE DISCUSSED. IT
SHORES CONTINUED FUNDING- AS
THEY STRUGGLE WITH WITH WITH
WITH THE PANDEMIC. THAT'S ALL
THIS IS LOOKING TO DO. AND WITH
THAT I RESPECT YOUR PRIVACY
THANK YOU SO MUCH CENTERONE NO
THIS IS A WORK IN PROGRESS IN
YOU ARE INCREDIBLY COMMITTED
AUTHOR ON. THIS BILL AND SO MANY
OTHERS HAVE DO APPRECIATE THAT%
ALL RIGHT WE HAVE A MOTION THE
FLOOR BY CENTER PAN THE MOTION
IS TO PASS IT FIRST BE REFERRED.
TO THE COMMITTEE AND
APPROPRIATIONS AND TURNED OVER
TO CHIEF CONSULTANT. TO RESTATE
THE MOTION CALL THE ROLL. BY
ITEM NUMBER FOR S. FIVE SEVENTY
NINE THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT
FIRST BE RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
SENATOR LEYVA. THAT ARE LEYVA SB
FIVE SEVENTY NINE HI LEYVA I AM
TROUBLED- OR CHARITABLE SB FIVE
SEVENTY NINE I FOR CHOI BOGUE ON
A COURTESY HI FOR TENNESSEE I'D
DALLY. DALY SB FIVE SEVEN NINE
NOT VOTING. DELHI NOT VOTING
GLAZER AYE GLAZER AYE MCGUIRE
AYE MCGUIRE AYE PAN HI HI SIX
ZERO SIX ZERO SIX ZERO VOTE THAT
BILL IS OUT WE'RE GOING TO CLOSE
THE ROLE LAYS IN GERMAN WE WANT
TO SAY THANK YOU THANK YOU TO
OUR CHIEF CONSULTANT FOR HER
WORK AS USUAL WANT TO SAY THANK
YOU TO SENATOR LEYVA FOR ALLOW
ME TO BE ABLE TO SIT IN THIS
SEAT TODAY- AND ALSO TO ALL OF
OUR MEMBERS INTO OUR AUTHORS FOR
THEIR WORK. THAT CERTAINLY THAT
WILL BE BACK WITH YOU HERE- FOR-
THAT COMMITMENTS TO TAKE US
THROUGH A NOTHER CHALLENGING BUT
I GOTTA TELL YOU INSPIRATION
YEAR PUBLIC EDUCATION THE CITY
CALIFORNIA WE'RE NOT GOING TO BE. OUR JOURNEY THANK YOU SO MUCH
EVERYBODY.